- One thing I love about American cons
is that they have events going on.
I remember going to my first British con
and you go there to drink.
- Half of my panels were in a bar area.
So while you're doing your panel,
people are lining up
to get beer and stuff.
(Joey laughing)
- I don't even know what
the biggest anime convention
in the UK is.
- Do you count MCM?
- [Garnt] I don't count MCM.
- Then I don't know what it is.
- What doesn't suck in UK?
(everyone laughing)
- Wow!
(slow music)
- Welcome to this episode of trash taste.
I'm with the boys, once
again, you know how it is.
Joey and Gar, and of course,
we have a guest today.
Kson, introduce yourself.
- Hello, thank you for having me today.
I am Kson the delinquent.
(everyone oohing)
- Most delinquent VTuber of all!
- I didn't think you were a delinquent.
You've been really polite so far.
- No, no, I haven't.
(everyone laughing)
- Alright, yeah.
- I mean, look at the way she's sitting!
- Yeah, look at the way she's posing,
she's gonna be doing that
for the entire podcast, what?
- I can poop here any time, you know.
- [Garnt] Oh my god!
- Please don't.
- That's how delinquent I am.
What?
- Only two people can sit
like this, L and Kson.
(everyone laughing)
- Yeah!
- I think you are the first guest
whose ever brought up poop before we have.
- Normally we have to apologize
whenever we bring up poop.
- Poop is our thing.
We usually start with poop.
- We normally, we've made
a pact not to bring it up
because we bring it up too often.
(everyone laughing)
- Look how delinquent I am, see?
- Just completely disregard
the golden rule of Trash Taste,
which is don't bring up
poop right from the get go.
- But I'm sure many are wondering, Kson,
why are you here in your VTuber form
and not your human form?
- [Garnt] That's true.
That's true.
- Oh!
Why not?
Because people love me in this form more!
- All right, all right.
- Yeah!
- Fair enough!
- They don't love you in the other form?
I'm sure they love you in the other form?
- I'm sure they love you in
the other form too, right?
- Is it that many people?
- Of course they do, but yeah,
but I kind of feel
comfortable in this form too.
- I get you, I get you.
- Because I don't have
to put my makeup on.
(everyone laughing)
- That is something
that I find very envious
with every Vtuber.
You just turn on the camera,
you don't need to like give
a shit about how you look.
- I usually don't give
a shit about how I look.
- I do morning streams.
I wake up, I look like I got
hit by a truck and I'm live
and everyone's like,
Connor, you look dead.
Every stream without fail, someone's like,
Connor you look tired.
Like, no shit.
That's what happens when you wake up!
- It could be 3:00 PM and
I still look like shit.
I just don't care anymore.
- I just permanently have eye bags.
So you can tell whenever I'm recording
something late at night
or early in the morning,
'cause I always, always without fail,
get the comments of, oh, have
you been sleeping enough?
I was like, oh, thanks mom.
No, I've been sleeping
enough, don't worry about it.
- Hi, general practitioner here.
It seems like Garnt's
not getting enough sleep.
- Oh my God!
- My god.
- Wait, do you prefer
actually doing Vtuber streams?
Or, how can I say, 3D
streams, IRL streams?
- IRL streams.
- You've done a lot of IRL, live action,
whatever the fuck you
want to call it before.
- I call it 3D high polygon model.
(everyone laughing)
- All right, all right, all right.
- Unreal engine four.
- It's a model for me.
For me, that's super high polygon model.
- Right, right.
- [Garnt] RTX (indistinct).
- Yes!
- Before we get into it, do you
wanna explain to the viewers
what you do and what you do for streaming
and everything like that?
- Oh yeah, I'm a delinquent VTuber.
I debuted on October 16th,
so I'm kind of a new one.
- A fresh face.
- [Joey] A fresh face.
- Yeah, fresh face but
I've been streaming for ...
I've been doing this for like three years
and five years ago I
started filming videos
of me playing games.
And then after that, well,
I thought I would like,
let's do the VTuber stuff
'cause I'm tired of
putting makeup on myself
and I'm tired of like-
- [Joey] Tired of the high polygon.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- [Connor] Cause you've done
a lot of cosplay stuff, right?
You did a lot of Cosplay streams, right?
- [Kson] Yeah, I love cosplay stuff.
I love Cosplay stuff.
- [Connor] But that's like the antithesis
of putting on makeup.
- Like you put a lot
of makeup on for that.
- Makeup's like step one, right?
And then it's like 20 steps after that.
- How much prep do you have
to do for a cosplay stream
whenever you are cosplaying someone?
- First of all, I make
all my cosplay costumes.
- [Garnt] Oh wow!
- I make it from scratch.
- Really?
- Yeah!
I'm good at sewing so I make it myself.
- [Garnt] Jeez.
- So step zero, I have
to buy the stuff and-
- Wow.
- Make it so (indistinct).
- You don't just buy from Wish
like this guy or whatever?
- You don't just buy it from Amazon?
- Yeah, man.
We're trying to find an adult
Minecraft Steve costume.
It's very difficult.
- I have a shirt and a pair of pants
that is the exact same
coloration as Minecraft Steve.
- I want like the blocks, right?
I've been trying to find
a Minecraft Steve costume
and it's been very difficult
'cause everyone I've purchased
or seen is for the ages of six to 12.
So I ended up just buying the
six to 12 one and fuck it,
I'll make it worse.
- [Garnt] Squeeze into it?
- I'll just rip that thing.
- Maybe I can make it for you!
- What?
- Yeah, you should give it to Kson!
- Yeah, give it to Kson.
- Can I do that?
Maybe I'll do that.
I don't know what your rates are.
It's probably very expensive.
- Actually, I didn't know
you made your own cosplays.
How long does it take to make one then?
- If I concentrate, maybe
for like three days, I can-
- If you use a hundred
percent of your brain.
- Yeah, a hundred percent of
my brain power and concentrate,
well, usually I can't do that
so it takes about like two weeks?
- Yeah, that sounds real
because like I've seen some
of your cosplay streams in the past.
- [Kson] Really?
- Yeah, and I remember
you did one for Bayonetta.
- [Connor] Yeah, the Bayonetta one?
That's the one where I
see clips everywhere.
- [Joey] Yeah, and I'm like,
how the hell did you
make that by yourself?
'cause that's better
than some professional
Bayonetta cosplays that I've seen.
- Oh, thank you.
- Was that the longest one you did?
What's the longest one that took you?
- Maybe Bayonetta because her hair!
Yeah!
It took more time than
the costume, her hair.
I had to buy like three wigs.
- Right.
- Three wigs and like mess
it up and did you see that?
- [Connor] We're putting on a picture
on screen and everything.
- [Kson] That mountain on
top of the head? (laughs)
- [Joey] That like hairband
thing that defies physics.
I don't know how that's built.
- [Connor] That's
actually Sponge Bob's home
that's been relocated.
- It was so hard, I had to
throw away like three wigs.
I messed up a lot of wigs
and so much money and time.
- (laughs)
- I can see why you do this now.
- Yeah, Vtubing!
- You've had a very long and
famous career doing this stuff
and it's really impressive.
One thing that I am kind
of weirdly impressed by,
because this is one thing that I find
that people really struggle to do,
is that you have mainly
a, is it correct in saying
you have a Japanese audience mainly?
- Yeah.
- But you also have an English following.
- And it's normally
really hard for creators
to balance two different languages.
- In fact, because like
a lot of the platforms
just don't want you to
speak both languages
because they want to know,
okay, you speak English,
we're recommending you
to English speakers.
You speak Japanese, only
Japanese speakers are getting it.
How do you find balancing that?
Because it's way beyond my ability.
- I'm figuring it out to be honest.
Like for the Japanese viewers,
they don't like me
speaking mostly in English
because obviously they won't understand.
(everyone laughing)
- Yeah, but mostly, my
viewers are mostly Japanese
and I mostly do the
streams in Japanese, so ...
- Sorry, what gave you the
idea to try and branch out
to a more international audience?
That's what I'm curious about.
Or was it just you had a language skillset
and you just wanted to flex it kind of?
- I don't know. Yeah,
maybe, maybe, yeah ...
- [Joey] I guess it's like, if you-
- Or is it dumb luck?
(everyone laughing)
- I'm just gonna give it
a go, see if it works,
kind of thing.
- Just wing it.
- Kind of like that.
I'm like, yeah, let's try it
and if it works out, good. (laughs)
I'm that kind of person.
- Well there you go, it worked out.
- I don't really think and
like strategize, I just do it.
- [Garnt] She's just a
genius, what can I say, right?
- [Joey] Just five head.
- Yeah, I'm just a genius delinquent.
Yeah, you could say that.
- I'm envious of you being able to speak
great Japanese and English.
Joey is also.
- Yeah, but the thing is I
haven't been able to diversify
my audience as much as Kson has I feel.
- Have you tried to capture
a Japanese audience at all?
And are you even interested in that?
- I'm personally just not
really interested in it.
Just because it's like, I don't know.
Because I feel it's just so different
in terms of content and stuff like that.
If it's kind of like what Kson does
where it's like whole
of variety stuff, right?
Where you can just basically
do whatever the hell you want,
then it's a little bit easier
to try and branch out, right?
But I don't know.
It's also a lot of effort to do both,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, I dunno if this is correct, right?
I could be completely wrong.
I've heard some stories about people
who have audiences both,
like some YouTubers,
they subtitle their stuff in Japanese
and they've quite a
decent Japanese following.
The main thing I've been told
is that Japanese people
have no chill online.
That's the one thing, the one criticism
that I've heard a lot.
- It's scary.
- At least that's from
an English perspective.
I don't know.
What is it like having the two
different types of audiences?
Do you notice a difference
between them both distinctly,
other than the language?
- Other than the language?
Well, I don't know.
Japanese people, it's just
from my perspective, okay?
- Of course, it's all opinion.
- [Joey] It's all your opinion.
- I just said they had no chill.
I think I'm in trouble probably.
- Japanese people mostly don't wanna see
my 3D high polygon stuff.
It's not like they don't
love me in that style,
it's like they could, I don't know,
relate more to the anime figure.
I don't know.
That's the part I don't
understand much about.
- 'Cause you're the same person, right?
- Yeah, we're the same person.
- One's 2D and one's a
3D polygon high model.
- You're not playing a character
or anything like at all,
are you?
- Well, I am a delinquent.
(everyone laughing)
- She is a delinquent.
- I'm not playing a character,
I'm just delinquent.
I was born delinquent.
And what was I talking about?
(everyone laughing)
- I guess though, it kind of makes sense
because otherwise, if
the Japanese audience
didn't have this like infatuation
with these 2D streamers,
then Vtubing wouldn't really
be a thing in the first place,
I feel.
- True.
- It's weird though.
- That infatuation had to
come from somewhere, right?
And Japan is already,
especially Japan's otaku culture
is already so obsessed
with the whole 2D thing.
- I got the Western brain.
That sounds like a disease.
I got Western brain.
I'm trying to wrap my head around it
as to give possible reasons.
- It's such a strange concept
because like my parents
don't understand the
whole VTubing thing all,
but they're always so curious being like,
why is it that people like this?
And it's so hard to explain to them why.
- They'll never understand.
My parents are like that too.
- Yeah, but even if I
brought up the whole debate
of Japanese people love 2D shit
and when you put a real person into it,
then it becomes more interactive,
they'll be like, why not
just show the real face?
And I'm like valid argument, parents!
But that's not how it works.
- [Kson] It doesn't work like that!
- My parents don't
understand anime period.
So trying to explain VTubers to them
is just like a whole 'nother level.
- It's like anime, but real.
- My parents haven't
asked me yet, luckily.
- Really?
- I had this the other day when
I went back home to England
and I had to explain to my
family members what VTubers was
and there was just so many
levels I had to explain
to even come close to
introducing the idea of Vtubers,
'cause they didn't know what streamers,
how streamers made money,
they didn't know what YouTube was worth.
So I needed to basically
explain the internet
before I could even start
explaining what VTubers are.
- Iron Mouse told me a
really fuckin' funny story
that her mom ...
So her mom doesn't understand it either
'cause mouse is really sick
and can't leave her house
and can't can't do anything really,
and her mom thought that
everyone who was a Vtuber
was sick.
And there's just something
so wholesome about that,
that I thought, awe.
I don't know why that just
warmed my heart in a weird way
where your mom was like,
is everyone the same?
And it's like no mom,
but thanks for asking.
- [Joey] It's a nice sentiment.
- Yeah, that was really (indistinct).
- How did you explain to your parents
when you started getting into VTubing?
- I didn't explain to them.
(everyone laughing)
- What did you tell them then?
- They know now, right?
- [Kson] Yeah, they know now
but they will never understand
so I just didn't. (laughs)
And my daddy still doesn't understand
anything about what I do, I think.
- Does he keep asking you
to get like a normal job?
- No, he doesn't do that,
but he like what the fuck is VTubing
and why does everyone pay money to you?
(everyone laughing)
- A solid argument.
- See, they're they're
on step two of parent.
Step one is the period where they're like
you should go get a real job.
And then step two is where
they've just given up on that
and they just start to
question what you do.
- 'Cause like I remember when
I first quit to do YouTube
and Patreon was my main form of revenue.
- [Connor] Yeah, my parents, oh my god.
- Yeah, and then I had
to explain to my parents
what Patreon was and
why that was basically
my monthly salary.
So I'm just like, yeah, so
just people pay me to be me
and do things that I did already,
and they're like, no, but
what are they paying you for?
Like to just to be me.
And they're like, no, no, no, no,
but what are you selling to them?
Like I'm not selling them anything.
- I mean to be fair,
I feel like you're
explaining it pretty badly.
You're just like just existing!
Just like welfare really,
but just specific for me.
- I mean, isn't that just
what YouTube ad revenue is?
- Welfare for YouTube.
- Yeah, welfare for YouTube.
A bit too generous I think the welfare is.
Oh my god.
Very generous welfare, Jesus Christ.
- When you're starting off,
it's like welfare, right?
- Yeah, I guess so.
- So going back to the language thing,
are you surprised how much of a potential
there was in an international audience?
Because Vtubing until
like the last few years
was very much a Japanese
thing, it was a Japanese idea,
and I think a lot of
your content made it so
that it was more accessible
to people in the West.
So were you surprised at all
with the rise of Vtubing just globally?
- I was really surprised.
I thought like, just like
my daddy had some allergies
about these internet Vtubing things,
I thought it was the same
for those Western viewers
to have this anime ....
- [Garnt] Anime avatar.
- Avatar thing talking to you like that,
maybe it will feel weird,
but I thought it was a really fun thing
and I just wanted to introduce to them,
there's something like
this and it's really fun.
If you don't like it, it's fine,
but just take a peek at it.
And it went good!
- Oh, and they took a
peek at it all right!
(everyone laughing)
- It's kind of crazy how
much it blew up in the West,
I guess, really.
It was almost overnight
it feels like it blew up.
Was it overwhelming at the time?
- Of course it was.
Of course it was!
- I bet it was overwhelming
when it was happening
in the Japanese audience as well, right?
- Yeah, true, true.
Why are all these
English people coming in?
What the fuck?
- It's like you only had to worry about
one small island nation worrying about it
and now you have the entire
world looking at you.
It's scary.
- It's kinda like anime itself, right?
Where a lot of it was originally just
everyone thought that only
Japan cared about anime
and now it's getting to a point where
it's just becoming the
mainstream cool thing
for all your kids to be watching anime
and like you're bullied now
for not watching anime and now-
- Now kids have it easy.
(everyone laughing)
- I remember I had
monthly Discord hangouts
where some of the members
who are in my discord group
have been watching me for
like seven to 10 years,
and it's like that already blows my mind,
but every so often we get
someone new into the group
and normally, everyone introduced myself
by saying their favorite anime
and saying their waifu or husbando,
and in the past few years, it
used to always be anime waifu
or anime husbandos but now
every time someone new comes in,
it's always Vtubers now.
- [Kson] Yeah, favorite Vtubers.
Vtuber waifus.
- It's the oshiis now.
- Oh right, Vtubers, a lot
of them getting figures.
A lot of them getting Nendoroids.
- Nendoroids!
- Like really official lines
which is pretty crazy, right?
I think if you'd have said
that like two years ago,
everyone would be like, no.
- [Joey] Well, I think-
- Kizuna Ai, right?
- Yeah, when Kizuna Ai started blowing up
and she got her own figure
and stuff like that.
- Selling NFTs.
- Yeah, selling NFTs.
- Oh no!
- I was like whoa, what the fuck?
This is so weird!
- The figures?
Yeah, it was so cool.
- Yeah, when the figures
came out it was nuts.
But now it's just like pretty normal.
- Yeah.
- Super normal.
- Yeah, when's your
figure coming out, Kson?
- Uhhh!
- [Joey] Eventually?
- I'm just a newcomer!
- As a Vtuber you can sell two things:
A figure and NFTS.
(everyone laughing)
- I was wondering where
you were going with that.
- I was like figure and Nendoroids?
- I was like figure and super chats?
- Thankfully, we haven't
gotten to that point,
I don't think, yet, but ...
- 'Cause you could sell yourself, right?
As an NFT.
- Stop, stop.
- Is that not what they're doing?
- We don't need this idea to
be in our brains right now.
- Yeah, I just kind of clock
out whenever I see NFT now.
I just stop looking.
I don't read any article,
I don't want to look at it.
- And yet you're the one
that keeps bringing it up on the show!
- Okay, one more thing before
I stop talking about NFT,
have you seen the clip of
Keanu laughing at NFTs?
- [Joey] No.
- [Garnt] I have.
- No?
It's so good.
There's this clip where this
guy talks to Keanu Reeves
about NFTs and he just starts giggling.
He mentions something
about replicating it.
- [Man] He was like and
replicates it! (laughs)
(everyone laughing)
- [Garnt] It's such a good reaction.
- [Joey] I didn't see that.
- Sorry for bringing that up.
- Just the idea of gacha
NFTs, that scares me so much.
- [Connor] Don't tell them that, Garnt.
- Yeah, you just gave them an idea now.
- [Kson] Ohhhh.
- Every gacha company's like ...
- All I'm saying is gacha
companies don't make enough money.
(everyone laughing)
- [Connor] I think they
make more than enough!
- That was a sarcastic joke right there.
That was /s sarcasm.
- Garnt got into fuckin' Fate
and their quarterly revenue went up.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- Do you play any gachas
or any of those games?
- No, no, no.
- Thank god, thank god, Kson!
Thank god.
- [Joey] Good choice, you're a real one.
- No.
- [Garnt] Yeah, stay away.
- I'm the real.
- You don't need to
fall into that hellhole.
- What's your addiction, if
you have one of any sort?
What are you into?
- My addiction?
Let me think.
- Other than Adidas.
- Okay.
- That's not an addiction,
that's a lifestyle.
- That's true, that's true.
- Adidas squat.
See my costume has Adidas lines in it?
- Does it really?
- See, see?
- Oh shit, yeah!
- Look, look, look!
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- [Garnt] Oh yeah.
- Yeah, it's Adidas.
(everyone laughing)
I can't say that loud.
- What's your passion then?
Any games or anything that
you're super addicted to?
- Super addicted to?
Let me think.
- As long as it's not gacha, it's a win.
- [Garnt] Streaming. (laughs)
- Yeah, I'm addicted to
streaming, of course.
- [Garnt] Right.
- I'm a full time streamer so yes.
But right now I'm addicted
to Far Cry. (laughs)
- Oh really?
- [Joey] Far Cry?
- Which one, the new one?
- Right now I'm playing Far Cry five.
- Oh, are you going through them all?
- Yeah, yeah!
- Oh okay, okay.
I heard they get worse
and worse as they go on.
- [Joey] Are they?
- Spoilers.
- I dunno, I dunno.
- I've only played three, I think.
- Yeah.
- Was that the good one? (laughs)
- Hey!
- I think three is the good one.
- I enjoyed it!
I enjoyed playing three.
- What's your favorite Far Cry so far?
- I've only played five.
I just started, I just started.
- Oh, oh!
- [Joey] Okay.
- [Garnt] Oh, you've
only played Far Cry five?
- [Kson] Yeah, I started
from Far Cry five.
- She's already into Far Cry from five.
- I thought she played
Far Cry one to five.
All right!
- [Connor] We're being lied to.
- Goddamn.
- [Kson] Is Far Cry five
the good one or the ...
- Ehh ...
I don't think Metacritic
likes it but you know.
- Is that the one with the-
- [Connor] The rednecks.
- Oh no, I just know the one with Gus.
- [Connor] That's the new one, six.
- Okay, six.
- [Connor] Gus Fring.
He's the meme of we're not the same.
I can't unsee that meme.
- Oh, that guy!
- Yeah. (laughs)
- All right.
- From Breaking Bad?
I was gonna say you haven't
seen Breaking Bad yet have you?
- No!
- Have you watched Breaking Bad?
- I've never seen it before.
- Oh my god!
- I only know the we
are not the same meme.
- It's so good!
- Okay, I gotta watch it!
Netflix, go on! (laughs)
- So you've been playing Far Cry,
and then we played Minecraft.
- Oh, yeah, I have my own
server, I just started it.
- Oh, you did?
- I'm playing with my friends.
- Well, thank you for
killing me on my server.
- Um, I'm not gonna say sorry for that
'cause-
- [Joey] I bet you like
top ten anime betrayals
I saw that happen.
- I was invisible, to be fair.
I'll give you the benefit of the doubt,
and then you went and
killed yourself anyway
like two minutes later so it was okay.
I think it was all right.
I think it was revenge was
well served by yourself.
But Minecraft is pretty
fun, I enjoy Minecraft.
Joey's a Minecraft expert.
- No, I'm not! (laughs)
- [Connor] He is, he's an expert.
- I'm not!
- [Connor] He's an expert in Minecraft.
- I just tried to get you into it.
- I opened the door for you.
- So you'd never played Minecraft before
you basically started streaming Minecraft?
- [Connor] No, yeah, yeah.
- I really want to get into it but-
- [Joey] The first time
he played Minecraft
was with me in the old studio.
- Oh!
- How many times you played Minecraft now?
- Um, I just started.
I'm just a beginner.
I don't know how to-
- It's really overwhelming, right?
- Yeah!
- There's so much to do.
- Is it fun?
- [Kson] What?
- It's a simple question,
can I not ask it, Joey?
(everyone laughing)
- I don't know, it's the most
boomer thing I've ever heard!
- [Connor] The desperation.
- What's this Minecraft thing?
- I've never played it before, okay?
- Is this mining crafting thing fun?
- I want to ask the gamer
if it is fun or not.
- It depends what you like to do.
Luckily, Minecraft is varied
so you can do what you want.
On the V shoujo server, which I played on,
they were just all building things
and I didn't want to build things.
- [Joey] Like houses and big structures?
- I wanted to go and do the raids.
- I want to have a goal,
that's the biggest-
- Yeah, well, there's bosses
and raids in this modded one.
So I wanted to just go and
explore and kill things
and level up.
- That's the good thing
about Minecraft, right?
You can do anything you want.
- You can do whatever you want, man.
- Your imagination is the limit.
- You can code in Minecraft.
- Can you actually?
- Yeah, there's redstone
and you can code with it.
- Yeah, there's a dude who made
a fully functioning computer
in Minecraft using redstone.
- [Kson] What?
- Yeah, yeah, they made
Pokemon as well with Minecraft.
- [Kson] Wow!
- They programmed Pokemon into the game.
- They had a working cellphone.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do you remember?
I think it was a promotion
with AT&T or something?
- [Joey] Something like that, yeah.
- At least one of their phones works
'cause normally it doesn't.
- Where they code, I think
it was something like
they coded it into the game
so that when you put on a webcam,
the blocks moved according
to the webcam like pixels,
but it's all programmed in the game.
- Wow.
- It's a very powerful tool, yeah.
It's really cool.
- [Joey] It's something like that.
- It's pretty fun.
When you get into it and
you start to understand
a bit more about the
game, it gets more fun.
So I think you'll enjoy it.
- Whoa!
- And then if you get
bored, just go creative mode
and just do whatever the fuck you want.
- True, true.
- Is that camera thing with mods?
Does that work with mods?
- Ohh, I don't know if that's
a publicly available mod.
It might've been a one off for YouTuber.
- [Joey] It might have
been a one off thing, yeah.
- Was it Captain Sparkles?
- Something like that, yeah.
It was one of the big Minecraft YouTubers.
- I feel sad that I missed the
Minecraft boom in some ways.
- [Joey] It'll come back.
- It's kind of booming now.
- [Garnt] It never stops booming.
- (indistinct) boom right now?
- [Joey] It just kinda
does this right now.
- Now we're booming with content,
before it used to be just songs and shit
and that was so funny.
Those songs were great.
- [Joey] Oh, the animations?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I loved those.
Terrible.
- I feel like every time it dies,
it comes back with a vengeance.
- [Connor] It does.
- It comes back even stronger.
I feel like-
- It's like Goku.
- Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
- Oh god!
Oh my fucking god, Joey!
- All right, I filled my
anime quota for the episode.
Let's move on.
- Joey's mentioned anime, we're done.
- So NFTs, uh.
- Proving that I am the anime
man, we gotta every so often-
- It does come back,
you're right, you're right.
- [Joey] It does come back, yeah.
- Are you a big anime fan?
- Um yeah, I think I am.
- [Together] You think you are?
- You're talking to the
anime man right now!
- Yeah, 'cause the anime
man is in front of me
so I can't say (indistinct).
(everyone laughing)
- He doesn't watch any anime!
- The title still stands.
I've said every anime on a video so ...
- The title is enough.
I don't need to-
- I have actually named every anime.
- He's ascended now.
- The title alone scares people.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- What kind of anime do you like then?
- Yeah, what are you into?
- I grew up with Dragon Ball.
- Of course, of course.
- I loved Goku.
I can do Gohan's voice.
- Ooh, okay.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah, barely dead Gohan.
(Kson groaning)
- So to explain, this is
the Japanese voice, huh?
- 'Cause the Western Gohan
sounds very different.
- What made you want to learn this skill?
- I didn't learn it!
Some viewer told me that I
sound like a barely dead Gohan
and I should just go for it.
You're good at it, so I practiced.
- Yeah, it sounds pretty spot on.
- I'm a pro at barely dead Gohan.
- You almost kind of sound
like barely dead Goku as well.
It's pretty much the same voice.
- Yeah, 'cause it kind of (indistinct).
- Yeah, Gohan and Goku in the Japanese dub
do sound very, very similar.
- Yeah, I mean they are father
and son, it makes sense.
- I don't know the difference.
I don't know the difference.
- What?
Of Gohan and Goku?
- Yeah.
- Gohan's basically that.
(Kson groaning)
- I don't know anything about Dragon Ball.
- And Goku is like.
(Kson groaning)
(everyone laughing)
- Can you hear the difference?
- It's a very subtle difference,
only Dragon Ball fans.
- (indistinct) find the difference
between these two sounds.
- It's between dying Gohan and dying Goku.
(everyone laughing)
- Let's run it back a bit,
you said you don't know Dragon Ball?
- No.
- [Garnt] What?
- What?
- [Joey] What do you mean?
Have you ever watched
it or read it at all?
- No, never watched or read it, played it.
- So you only know it through osmosis?
- Yeah.
I know that they do the kamehameha?
(Joey laughing)
- [Kson] Oh my god!
- I think my dad might know more
about Dragon Ball than you do.
- I know the spirit bomb.
- [Joey] Yeah, that's another one.
- I know the hadouken, no, I'm kidding.
- [Joey] Shoryuken?
- Shoryuken, right?
That's it.
- [Garnt] I've never felt
such a bigger generation gap
than now, oh my god!
- Here's what happened, right?
- So wait, how many of the side characters
and their lores do you know?
Or anything like that?
You know Vegeta, right?
- I know Vegeta, I know Piccolo.
- Do you know who Vegeta marries?
- Bulma?
- [Joey] Yeah!
- Okay.
- That's just from people
on Twitter role playing it.
I'm like what the fuck is this?
- And do you know what
their kid's name is?
- Tanjiro?
(everyone laughing)
- Tanjiro!
Oh my gosh.
- Luffy?
- [Joey] No!
- What's the kid called?
- Trunks!
- I know Trunks.
I didn't know that was his kid.
- Yeah.
- I know Trunks 'cause there's a guy
who wanted to look like Trunks
and he dresses up and I saw that video.
- The guy who spent like
70k on himself, right?
- Have you seen this video?
There's a guy who wants to
look like Trunks in the US,
I think, and then he does
look like Trunks to be fair.
- But to be fair, he-
- [Kson] With plastic surgery?
- Yeah.
He gets plastic surgery and
he also colors his hair purple
and wears the thing.
- [Connor] It's really bizarre.
- But he's also jacked as shit.
- [Connor] Yeah, I mean
whatever makes you happy.
- [Kson] Wow!
- So he looks like a real
life Trunks, it's pretty cool.
- He seems like he's killin' it.
- As long as you're not hurting anyone,
as long as you're happy.
- Majin Buu.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah?
- That would have been really embarrassing
if I got that wrong.
- Do you know the villain
that comes before Majin Buu?
- [Connor] Yes, um, it is ...
- I'm just realizing every
fucking Dragon Ball reference
I've made during the last two years
you've just smiled and laughed.
- [Connor] No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
- It's been an entirely-
- [Kson] He didn't know shit!
- Our friendship is based
on a lie, what's going on?
- His obsession with drip Goku was a lie.
- [Kson] What's going on, Connor?
- Listen, drip Goku has
nothing to do with Goku.
- Connor's probably like oh
yeah, I love that episode
where he puts on the Supreme.
(everyone laughing)
- I love it when he puts
on the Supreme jacket!
- [Joey] That's my favorite episode ever!
- Are you aware of this
meme, the drip Goku meme?
- Oh yeah. (laughs)
- I actually have the jacket.
I didn't bring it with me
today though, unfortunately.
- I think I saw it on Twitter.
- Hell yeah!
I should have brought it
with, you could've been drip.
- I want to be drip!
- Oh my god.
- [Garnt] She's showing the Adidas drip.
- Oh true, true.
Brand loyalty, brand loyalty.
- [Garnt] Brand loyalty.
- I know the villain name, I know him,
the one who looks like a budget Mewtwo.
(Joey laughing)
- What?
Oh!
- I think he's talking about Frieza.
- Oh Frieza, that's it!
(everyone laughing)
That's it, Frieza!
- [Everyone] Frieza budget Mewtwo!
- I can't believe it!
- He looks like a budget Mewtwo!
- I'm pretty sure Frieza
came before Mewtwo.
- Did he?
- Yes!
- Of course!
- Which one's Frieza?
- Frieza is budget
Mewtwo according to you-
- Oh okay, right.
- But Frieza definitely
came before Mewtwo.
- [Connor] Oh, fuck.
- So Mewtwo is the budget Frieza.
- Oh shit, maybe you're right.
Fuck, I fucked up!
See, I understand Dragon Ball references
because I've been in
the otaku anime circle
where I understand Dragon Ball reference
and I'm like laugh now.
- You can't name any story
portion or anything like that.
- Sometimes I'll make a
joke being like oh my god,
this is so long, it's like a
Dragon Ball fight, you know?
What's going on?
And people will be like
ha, that's so real,
Connor knows Dragon Ball.
It's like that one time that
Vegeta and Goku were fighting
for like 20 episodes.
- That did happen.
- [Connor] Yeah, exactly, right?
See?
It's easy enough to figure out
what Dragon Ball fans like.
- To be fair though,
that was probably one
of the shorter fights.
- If you let me go in the zoo,
I'm sure I could fit in with the monkeys
after 20 minutes of watching.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like that.
- [Joey] To use that analogy.
- I'm sorry, I just wanted to take a jab
at Dragon Ball fans.
- [Joey] Just assimilate.
- I thought you were taking a
jab at yourself (indistinct).
- [Connor] No, no, no, no.
- Getting off Dragon Ball though,
is there any other animes
that you like as well?
- Naruto, of course.
- [Garnt] Of course.
- So you love Fortnite?
- Oh, that's-
- How do you feel about that?
- What's your favorite Fortnite character?
- You love them in Fortnite.
- But why the fuck did they do that?
(everyone laughing)
I mean, Kishimoto san, why?
Why did you say yes to that?
It's so fuckin' hilarious and I love it.
- I think what happened is
he saw where Boruto was going
and he's just like I've lost
all hope with this franchise.
- I have to revive it somehow.
- To be fair, watching him do the signs,
I don't know what they're called.
- [Joey] The jutsus?
- The jutsus and then just pull out a gun,
there's something really funny about that.
- I think we call that rasengun.
- Just do the hand thing
and whipped out an AK,
it's like what the fuck?
- And then do a Fortnite dance.
It felt like a fever dream
the first time I watched that.
- I think it was seeing
Sasuke do the Fortnite dance
that just really killed
my fucking childhood.
It wasn't the gun, it
was the Fortnite dance
and I'm just like ...
- [Kson] That was the best. (laughs)
- Just Kakashi flossing-
- It's only a matter of time
before we get Tanjiro doing it.
- Oh my god.
- I'm just like this is
what Itachi died for?
This?
Just fucking Sasuke
doing the Fortnite dance!
I'm just, I'm done.
- What other animes are you into?
It seems you're into the classics.
- [Garnt] The classic shounens.
- Yeah, I'm into the classic ones
and of course, Kimetsu and-
- That's how you fit in in Japan.
I've realized if I want to fit
in with any Japanese person
I'm like ah, Kimetsu no Yaiba.
- [Joey] Yeah, I like Kimetsu.
- They're like ah, I
know that, I know that!
I love that one!
- Yes, I too know water.
- It's like Kimetsu, One Piece, and Jojo.
- If you say those, more so
Kimetsu and One Piece, I'd say.
Jojo sometimes people
are like what's that?
- Yeah, Jojo's a specific demographic,
whereas Kimetsu's just everyone.
- Every single, even if
they're like 80-90 years old,
they know Kimetsu no Yaiba
and they've watched it.
And Jujutsu Kaisen weirdly now actually.
- Yeah, Jujutsu Kaisen is
pretty popular now, right?
- Yeah, weirdly so.
- Did you like Jujutsu Kaisen?
- I loved it.
I thought it was so good!
- I thought it was just okay.
- I don't know.
Here it is with Joey.
- [Joey] I don't know, like-
- Joey's like I don't know,
it's just a little too popular.
- No, no, no, no, it's not that.
I thought-
- [Connor] Do you like it?
- I'm on Joey's side with it.
- (gasps)
- I thought it had everything
that I thought I was going to like
but then the end result was
kinda like underwhelming?
- [Connor] What?
- I don't know.
- [Connor] Defend yourself.
- Wait, wait, wait,
before we start comparing,
what did you think of Demon Slayer then?
- I thought Demon Slayer was good.
- [Connor] Better than Jujutsu?
- Do you think it's on the same level?
- I think Kimetsu's better
than Jujutsu Kaisen personally.
- [Connor] Holding my tongue here.
- Fuck, man, fuck.
- Do you agree?
- [Kson] Yeah.
- What did you think was not
good about Jujutsu Kaisen?
- It's too complicated.
- What?
- No!
- It wasn't even that
complicated! (laughs)
- What was it for you, Joey?
- I understood everything.
- Tell me your argument!
- I don't know.
It just kinda had every trope
that we've already seen.
- [Connor] Yeah, but-
- That's just Demon Slayer!
That's literally Demon Slayer!
- Yeah-
- I felt like it did the tropes the best.
That's what made it stand out
is that it took the tropes
and it did some other things
that were interesting as well,
and it just did it better than anyone.
- I'm not saying it was a
bad show, I enjoyed the show,
I just don't think it's as
good as people say it is.
- I think it deserves the hype
way more than Demon Slayer does.
- Watching Jujutsu Kaisen
and then watching shit
like My Hero Academia,
it's like going from a five
course meal to a plain cracker.
- Oh dude, I would watch
Jujutsu over My Hero
any day to be honest.
Do you like My Hero Academia?
- Um better than Jujutsu Kaisen maybe.
- [Joey] Oh, really?
See the different opinions
flying around today.
- I really regret inviting you right now!
- What?
- We can't agree on anything.
- I didn't think I'd get
passionate about anime today
'cause it's trash taste
but I'm getting passionate
about anime today.
- This is like the is Fortnite
overrated conversation.
(everyone laughing)
This is literally that!
This is literally that conversation.
We're talking about are anime
overrated, fuckin' hell.
I hate my life.
Did you watch Arcane?
- No, I don't know that.
- Watch Arcane.
- Oh, thank god.
- [Kson] Okay.
- [Connor] Please, it's so good,
it's so good, it's so good.
Please watch it, please watch it.
- Okay. (laughs)
- But we all agree that One
Piece is the best, right?
- Yes.
- I haven't watched One Piece.
Have you watched One Piece?
- Kson, you watch One Piece as well?
You've read it, watched it?
Read it, watched it?
- I read it.
- How far did you get in it?
- This is like when my
mom asked me if I studied.
- Sanji joined.
Sanji joined!
- That's like chapter 20!
(everyone laughing)
- [Connor] Hell yeah,
we're on the same page!
- That's not even the epilogue, yeah.
That's not even prologue.
- I've read zero chapters.
- [Joey] But you're going to, right?
- I am going to.
Again, I've only watched
the 4Kids version.
- I'm sorry.
- Again, I think I've mentioned it before,
the stuff I read about.
- Tell me when you start reading it
and I will also re-read from where I am
so that we can all be up to speed.
- Okay.
- I was kind of curious,
do you watch and play stuff
that your stream basically recommends?
'Cause I notice working in the field,
some of the recommendations I
get of what to watch and play
basically just come from my audience.
So I'm wondering is that how
you guys, not just to Kson,
but is that how you guys
basically choose what media
to consume nowadays as well?
- Um I'd say mostly yes, yeah,
'cause I don't get any
information from other friends.
They never leave home,
they don't know anything,
they don't watch TV shows. (laughs)
- Are they in prison?
- (indistinct) for anything like that.
- I guess you've got
to follow your audience
to some capacity, right?
Just 'cause you are performing,
quote unquote, to them
when you're on stream and stuff like that.
- Do you get a lot of free time?
Because we've had previous
Vtubers on before-
- She's a streamer, of course she doesn't!
- Of course!
I do nothing!
(everyone laughing)
- You sounded so happy about that.
That felt so sad.
- Otaku dream, right?
Just doing nothing.
- Just do nothing.
- Initially with Vtubing, what
made you want to go for that?
Was it purely just for not
wanting to put makeup on
or was there something about
that you were leaning towards
with the whole Vtubing that
made you want to go for it
in the first place?
- I just thought Vtubing was cool
and it looked like it's
gonna make some movement
or something.
- I thought you were about to say money.
(everyone laughing)
- Money!
- That sounded like a money!
- Yeah, money!
Yeah.
- Did you have any
streamers that inspired you
to start Vtubing in the first place?
- Of course, Kizuna Ai san.
She was so inspiring.
Did you guys watch the Backstreet Boys,
that movie of Kizuna Ai chan singing?
Everybody, yeah!
- Are you serious?
- [Joey] Wait, what?
- That was the one that
got me into Vtubing stuff.
- Really?
- Yeah!
- Wait, so what is it?
- That was an MMD though, wasn't it?
- [Man] It was an MMD.
- Yeah, I thought so.
Yeah, I didn't know if
it was Vtubing or MMD
but it felt like the animation.
- Yeah, it's kind of like a Vtubing ...
- So the Backstreet Boys
got you into Vtubing?
- Not like that but-
(everyone laughing)
Did I say that?
- That's a good sentence, I think.
- That's like the domino image, right?
- Kson, Backstreet Boys.
- Backstreet Boys forms,
Kson becomes a Vtuber.
- The whole Vtubing industry.
(everyone laughing)
Backstreet Boys.
- Backstreet Boys, yeah.
- Justin Timberlake.
- [Man] It was MMD models of
Kizuna Ai that sang at you?
- Hold on, did you just say,
did you say Justin Timberlake?
- That's Nsync!
Fuck!
- Nsync.
- Yeah, Justin Timberlake is
Nsync not Backstreet Boys.
- I made a mistake.
- It's all right.
- So before you started
streaming on YouTube,
were you mainly on YouTube
like watching stuff on YouTube
or were you on Niconico as
well and other JP sites?
- I was on Niconico.
I didn't know much about YouTube
because I didn't watch it.
I just didn't.
I didn't find any content
interesting for me.
- What's the Niconico community like?
'cause a lot of people who
obviously can't speak Japanese
and especially the international audience,
to me it feels like it's it
own very tight knit community
with it's own culture
and everything like that.
- For me, it was the only platform I knew.
- Right.
So your perception of the internet
was just Niconico for you, right?
Yeah.
- Yeah, Niconico.
- I feel it was like that though,
'cause I used to be on Niconico as well
when I was in high school
and they have their own memes
that just never leave Niconico.
- So were you watching
Niconico from high school?
- I was watching Niconico ...
I started watching when I was in college
and yeah, I think I was
in college that I started
because my parents
never let me play games.
They were ...
- [Joey] Awe, like super strict.
- [Garnt] Super strict.
- Super strict about it.
They were like games make you stupid,
don't you ever do that.
Those kind of parents!
My parents were like that.
- Did they let you watch anime?
- No, never!
- Wait, wait, so what did you
do in your free time as a kid?
- I was hiding under my bed
and reading Dragon Ball.
(everyone laughing)
- [Joey] The true delinquent!
- True delinquent!
- The delinquency started
from such a young age.
- Of course!
When they say not to do it-
- You want to do it.
- Of course!
- [Joey] Of course, of course.
- And now, look what
I'm doing, daddy, mommy,
I'm playing games!
(everyone laughing)
- I'm playing games and
talking about Dragon Ball!
- And now I am anime!
- [Kson] I am anime!
- Goes full circle.
- Yeah!
- So you were watching it in college
and then when did you think oh man,
I kinda want to join in on this?
- When I started working,
one of my colleagues
he talked to me like do you like games?
And he started talking about games
and we became good friends
because I was really interested in games
because I started to make money myself
and I was buying a lot of games!
- Hell yeah.
Hell yeah!
- I was living by myself so
there was no one to stop me.
So I was like buying a
lot of games, playing it,
enjoying it, and my colleague
was like there are streamers
playing games online, do you watch it?
And I got interested in it
and I started watching it,
and then he said like I
want to stream like them.
How about we do it together?
Yeah, he suggested let's do
the streaming stuff together.
We ended up never doing it together
because I don't know, he
just disappeared! (laughs)
He quit the job.
(humming Twilight Zone theme song)
He got me into this, I want
to still do it with you
but he just disappeared.
So fuck it, I'll do it myself
and I started making movies.
It was just recording it
and just cutting the end,
it was something like that.
It's not making something.
- [Garnt] You mean like let's plays?
- Yeah, the let's plays.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] All right, all right, all right.
- And I started posting it on Niconico
and that was my start.
It was like 2017.
- So you had a job before
you were doing this
and you were doing the job
while you were posting this stuff as well?
- Yeah.
- Am I allowed to ask what you did before?
- I was working ...
Let's keep it a secret!
(everyone laughing)
- No worries.
- Good choice.
- I was working hard!
- I was on that grind.
- At a job where colleagues disappear!
(everyone laughing)
- Where colleagues often disappear.
- The delinquent life has
been strong with this one.
So how long were you posting
let's plays for then?
- For like three years, I think?
- Oh wow.
And did it ever pick up or was
it just not that many viewers
throughout the whole time?
- My very first video that I
posted on Niconico came viral.
- What?
- The very first one, so
I was thankful about that.
- I need to ask, what
is viral on Niconico?
- Niconico on viral it means like
there's a ranking in Niconico.
You guys know Niconico rankings?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Is it like one to 10 or something?
- It will display ranking
and it was like ranking
one to five was mine.
- Oh wow!
- It's basically like weekly or monthly,
something like that, right?
- Yeah, something like that.
- [Connor] Like old YouTube then.
- Yeah, so basically at
the front page of Niconico
usually there's a ranking for
the top videos for this week
or the top videos for this month
and then they just have links.
That's their algorithm thing.
- What was so special about this video?
- I don't honestly-
- I imagine if it's your first
video, it's probably bad.
- It's super bad!
- [Joey] She was just
born to be a streamer!
- What made it blow up?
- I don't know.
The very first video that I posted
was me struggling with Japanese
but trying to play it in Japanese,
and the first one I was
playing the game Siren.
You guys know Siren?
- Oh, Fatal Frame.
No, not Fatal Frame, is it?
No, no.
- Is it a horror game?
- No, it's a different one, right?
Yeah, it's like Fatal Frame though, right?
- Was it just you raging at the Japanese?
- Yeah!
- I could see why that
would do well actually.
- [Joey] I can see how that would do it.
- And I think no one did that before.
- And you did that for three years?
And it just kept growing?
- I wasn't constantly doing that.
I was throwing videos on Niconico
and do nothing for half a year.
- Just disappear?
- Just disappear and working.
- I relate to that.
That's what I did.
- Yeah, that's what I did
for the first three years.
I just throw the video to
Niconico and do nothing.
Throw some more, do nothing.
- I feel though like it's
pretty rare on Niconico
for there to be content
creators that constantly produce
because you don't make money on Niconico.
- [Kson] Nothing.
- [Connor] So it's just for the clout.
- Yeah, people just do it
because they want to make some shit.
- They're just passionate.
They're just passionate in their content.
- [Connor] Fuck, bro!
- Can you imagine?
- That's the biggest crime alive.
Doing something for free.
Hell no, not in this economy!
(everyone laughing)
- Honestly, sometimes
you see Niconico content
that gets reposted on YouTube
and it's absolutely fucking insane
some of the content (indistinct).
- Some of the edits are just ridiculous.
- [Kson] It is!
- Yeah, like seeing some of the mad edits
during the peak of the AMV years
where you thought there was
some mad talented AMV editors,
which there are, and then out of nowhere
you just get this mad clip
that just got posted from Niconico
and it was just fuckin'
insane what they were doing
compared to what you could see on YouTube.
- Like all the Vocaloid producers
used to upload their shit
onto Niconico for free.
- [Kson] Yeah, yeah, yeah,
they all started from there.
- Yeah, it all started from
there and they just did it
not because they were
making money off of it,
just because they were I
made this song, check it out.
- Check it out, how do you feel?
- [Joey] Could you imagine?
- When I started in
university, I did it for fun
but that's 'cause in university
you haven't got bills to pay.
- [Joey] Right.
- The loans are paying your bills.
- [Garnt] Spare time as well, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, you
actually have time as well,
so that's fair.
- So when did you transfer over to YouTube
and what made you transfer over platforms
to YouTube in the first place?
- Well, the viewers told me.
They were like it'd be
easy to watch it on YouTube
than Niconico.
They just told me that so okay,
then I'll do it on YouTube,
and it felt like it was more easier for me
to stream on YouTube because
to stream on Niconico,
it's kind of complicated.
You have to put all those
softwares in your PC
and it was so complicated for me,
and it felt like it was really easy for me
to do it on YouTube so I just
went to YouTube and here I am!
- I think it's also
because the Niconico system
just hasn't changed at all.
- I think it looks like it's
on Live leak on Niconico.
The quality's so-
- Live leak?
- You don't want to know.
- Yeah, you don't want to know about it.
- I remember before, I'd
heard about Niconico,
as an anime fan you'd hear
about this mythical website
that all the Japanese
people use called Niconico,
and I remember trying to
watch some videos on it
and even just watching a video,
with YouTube or basically
any Western video website,
all you need to do is just go on the site,
search up a video, click on the video,
and you can watch the video.
So I remember clicking
on some Niconico links
and you have to sign
up to a special account
just to watch videos
or something like that.
- Yeah, if you don't have
an account on Niconico
you can't watch anything.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Oh.
- And then I remember
I couldn't understand
what all this text flying
across the screen was.
(everyone laughing)
I was just like what is this?
- [Connor] Oh yeah, that's right!
- This is ruining my viewing experience!
- I can't see anything!
- This is blocking the content,
how are people watching this right now?
- If you watch speed running
something salt videos,
whenever they have runners
from Japan from Niconico
and you can just see-
- [Joey] See all the comments.
- Yeah, yeah, all the things
flying across the screen.
Oh my god.
- I remember one time, I
think it was on Niconico,
where one of the Madoka episodes
got streamed on Niconico
and I didn't know how to figure out
how to turn off the comments.
So basically, whenever
anyone quoted something big,
whenever Madoka would say a line,
you'd see like a line of comments
just quoting the episode
before she said it, right?
So it was literally like
that movie experience
where you're sitting next to someone
who's quoting the entire film.
(everyone laughing)
It was like that but online basically.
- Today's episode is sponsored by honey.
- [Joey] We all shop online
and we've all seen that
promo code field taunting us
at the checkout, but thanks to Honey,
manually searching for coupon codes
is a thing of the past, gentlemen.
Honey's the free browser extension
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best ones
it finds to your cart.
- [Connor] Honey supports
over 30,000 stores online.
- [Joey] What?
- They range from having
tech and gaming products
to popular fashion brands
and even food delivery.
- All right, guys, here's
how it works, all right?
Imagine you're shopping at
one of your favorite sites.
When you're at the checkout,
the Honey button drops down
and all you have to do
is click apply coupons,
wait a few seconds as Honey searches
for all the coupons it
can find for that site
and if Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch as the prices drop.
(men screaming)
- I recently spent a lot
of money on plushies,
over $100 to be in fact,
and I saved $20 using Honey.
- But Honey hasn't just
saved Connor a lot of money.
- That's me.
- Honey has found it's
over 70 million members
over $2 billion dollars
in savings, gentlemen.
(Connor gasping)
- If you don't already have Honey,
you could be straight up
missing out on free savings.
So what are you waiting for?
Get Honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
- Oh my god, back to the episode.
Kson, I need to know.
- What?
- Have you watched Jojo?
That's my passion, my love in life.
- I'm afraid to say no.
- Cancel the episode.
Cancel it!
Mudon, end the episode!
- You dare sit behind and
call yourself a delinquent
when Jojo practically invented
delinquents, I'm pretty sure?
- [Joey] Before Jojo
there was no delinquents.
- There was no delinquents
before Josuke, bro.
Pay your respects.
Okay.
- The god of delinquents, Josuke.
- He's actually a very nice
guy, helps the community out.
So he's hardly a delinquent.
No, I'm kidding.
- I think you would love it though.
- I think you'd like it a lot.
- Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Can I ask you this?
Is Kishibe Rohan a part of Jojo?
- He is indeed.
- [Joey] He's in part four.
- How'd you know about Kishibe Rohan?
- Oh, I've seen that before!
I've read that Kishibe Rohan comics.
I know that part.
(everyone laughing)
- Oh, the immovable Kishibe Rohan.
- Yeah, but I didn't know it was Jojo.
- You watched the spinoff?
- It's a spinoff? (laughs)
- That's like watching the
Jar Jar Binks web comic
instead of watching Star Wars!
- It's like watching the
Star Wars Christmas special
before Star Wars.
- [Kson] Oh no!
- I've heard of people skipping parts.
- [Connor] That's a whole new thing!
Start with the Rohan Kishibe.
- I've heard of skipping parts
which is meant to be the
biggest sin to any Jojo fans.
What level do we put just
starting with the side story?
- Were you not confused?
- No!
- Because that spinoff is
confusing even for fans
because the episodes aren't
in the correct order.
- Characters just turn up as
well that we know from prior.
Did you like it?
- I really liked it.
- Then you'll love Jojo!
- Then you should go and watch proper,
the not the spinoff Jojo.
- I can't believe, I can't
look you in the eye right now.
- Am I gonna get killed after this?
- No, I'm just disappointed,
Kson, I'm just disappointed.
- Oh!
- Something about your energy though
says that I think you'll
really become a Jojo fan.
- If you loved the Rohan
Kishibe one, you will love Jojo.
- Really?
- 'Cause Rohan Kishibe is just Jojo.
- Wait, wait, wait, Jojo has bus right?
Ichibu, nibu.
- I thought you said boobs there.
- [Joey] Yeah, I was like-
- I was like Tequila Joseph?
- Six, I guess?
Yeah, yeah, so it's split up into parts
and then each of the different parts
have a different protagonist.
- [Connor] Different main character, yeah.
- But Kishibe Rohan's not a protagonist.
- Oh, it's not?
- [Connor] He is a main character though.
- He's an important side character.
- [Connor] Very important, very important.
- He's a side character
that everyone loves.
- He's a side character but
he's not in any of the ichibu,
nibus, any of the-
- He's in yonbu.
- Oh, he's in yonbu.
So I started from yonbu?
- Kinda yeah.
- You kind of started from 4.5.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 4.5?
Is that a sin?
God Connor?
- I'm not pleased that you started there.
How did you even start there?
How did that happen?
Netflix?
- No, I read the Jump comics.
- [Together] Ohh, okay.
- That makes a-
- Understandable.
- That makes a little more
sensewise for that to happen.
Understandable, have a nice day.
- Understandable but unforgivable.
(everyone laughing)
- No!
- Oh my god, I wish I could
have watched you reading it
just to see how confused
you must have been.
What the fuck is going on?
- But I enjoyed it!
- It's fun.
I really liked the Rohan Kishibe OVA.
- [Joey] It's a great side story.
- The anime is amazing as well.
I gotta say, my favorite one,
did you read all of
the Rohan Kishibe OVAs?
Or just some of them?
- [Garnt] Side story.
- Side stories.
- I don't know.
I don't know.
- Okay, let me know if
this sounds familiar.
Tell me if this sounds familiar.
He goes to a gym and there's a guy
who he's running with at the gym.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah! (laughs)
- Have you read this one?
- No.
- I love this one so goddamn much.
- [Joey] You love that one, yeah.
- It's just like, I don't
even know how to explain it.
He just goes to the gym and
starts racing against a guy
who then wants to then beat him.
- Wait, I know that, I know that story!
- It's so good.
This does not get memed enough.
It's like peak Jojo.
Have you seen it?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's so good.
The guy is just obsessed with
protein and then oh my god,
it's just so good.
I love it.
Please watch the Rohan
OVAs if you like Jojo,
you will love it.
- [Garnt] Just watch
Jojo in general, right?
- It's amazing.
It's amazing.
- Yes, ma'am, I'll start, okay.
- But I'll tell you the order
you have to watch it in.
So you start with one and then you go two.
- [Kson] And then two, okay.
- And then you go three.
- [Kson] And three.
- Yeah, and then you go four.
- Kson's already broken that.
- That's true.
- Rohan Kishibe's side story,
then part nine probably.
(everyone laughing)
- First chapter of part nine.
- All right, so you haven't watched Jojo.
What are you currently into then?
What do you on that now?
- I'm into Gundam right now.
- Didn't expect that.
- (indistinct) Gundam.
- Like gunpla and stuff?
- Yeah, gunpla!
I started making gunpla stuff.
I'm doing a gunpla making
stream and it's really fun!
- It's a rich man's hobby.
- What's your favorite Gundam?
- My favorite Gundam?
I'm a fan of Turn A.
- Ah, Turn A Gundam, okay.
- I understand.
- I like (indistinct) too.
- I like the metal orphans one.
- [Together] You mean
Iron Blooded Orphans?
(everyone laughing)
- I don't know anything
about Gundam, I'm so sorry!
- I like the metal hemoglobin orphans.
- I don't know anything about Gundam!
I'm just, again, pretending.
- I think we're all pretending
because the only Gundams
I've seen, unfortunately,
are like the mainstream Gundams like-
- Like Wing?
- Like Wing, 00, Gundam Seed,
which all Gundam fans want to forget.
- Have you been a fan of
Gundam for a long time
or is it just recently you got into it?
- Recently, I'm just learning.
- When did you get into it?
- First of all it was gunpla.
I love making stuff.
- Cosplay, yeah.
- Yeah, cosplay.
I love sewing, I love making little stuff.
I began making Gundam.
I got into it, I don't
know, because I had time,
I'm a streamer!
- To be fair, it is
perfect streamer content.
- It's like a just chatting stream
with something to distract you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I really wanted to get into it as well,
but I know so little
about the gunpla world
that I didn't even know where to start.
- Yeah, you didn't even
know about the grades.
- I didn't even know
about the grading system.
- I don't know that, I don't know.
- Yeah, there's HG.
- [Joey] Which is high grade?
- I think it stands for high grade.
- Are these all on the boxes?
- It's on it.
- I didn't know this, why
has no one told me this?
- [Joey] Me neither.
- HG for beginners, so
I'm starting from HG.
- And 4k.
- I just recently made RG, which is-
- [Man] Real grade.
- Is it real?
- [Garnt] Real grade.
- Real grade?
And on top of that there's MG.
- Is this the imperial
system or something?
- Perfect grade isn't the top?
I can't remember.
- Oh wait.
- [Man] Perfect grade's the top.
- I thought perfect grade was-
- Perfect grade is on top of MG?
Master grade?
- We've got a tier list motherfucker.
(everyone laughing)
- And then PG is predator grade obviously.
- Predator grade!
- Hell yeah, I can get into that.
- The only reason I know about gunpla
is mostly through my editor, Alan,
who's also a big mecha fan.
- He's obsessed with Gundam.
- Big Gundam fan as well.
I've built a few gunpla in my life.
- A Code Geass one?
- Huh?
Is that the Code Geass gunpla?
- Mm-hmm (affirmative), yeah.
- Actually, do you want how I started off
discovering gunpla?
- What?
- So my cousin, 'cause here's the thing,
gunpla and Gundam and mecha in general
was super, super massive in Southeast Asia
and I know a lot of people who actually
they don't even know Gundam
but they build gunpla
because they're just a
massive fan of gunpla.
- Yeah, I think that's me right now.
- Yeah, exactly, right?
- Yeah, I don't watch much.
- The gunplas are more
appealing than the show for me.
- So I remember every time
I'd go to my cousin's house,
and if you've been watching Trash Taste,
this was the cousin that
showed me scary movies
when I was a kid, right?
So he's basically my older brother,
but I remember every
time I'd go to his house
he had this room and he had this cabinet
that was just basically gunpla.
It was all gunpla and that's
how I knew what gunpla was.
So I didn't know you had to build it.
So be me, I'm like five, six
year old, I see a cabinet
full of giant robots, what do I think?
They're toys!
- I'm gonna play with them.
- That's not on six year old
Garnt, that's not on you.
- Okay, so the first time I
remember going to that room,
he goes to the toilet for
something or his mom calls him,
I don't remember, but he
leaves me alone in that room
for like a good 15-20 minutes.
So what do I do?
I want to start playing with the toys.
(Joey groaning)
So I didn't know.
- Pain Olympics.
- Yeah, so I'm describing
the pain Olympics now.
So I see them all on the
shelf and I grab two,
I grab two off the shelf.
- [Connor] And they start fighting, right?
- And then of course, they're
giant robots in my hand,
what are they gonna do?
They're gonna start fucking fighting!
So I started (pow sounds)
'cause I think they're fucking
Transformers or something.
Was acting like the BBC.
But of course, so I started
playing around with them,
things start flying off.
(Joey groaning)
I think the fucking laser sword breaks.
I don't fucking know,
I'm like six year old,
and when my cousin comes in,
he literally had a bottle of
water in hand, he drops it.
You know that scene in a movie
where the person sees something
and they drop the coffee?
He actually just fucking did that
and I didn't know he was in the room
until I heard the water bottle dropping.
- Falls in slow motion.
- Oh!
- Ooh what you say?
- And this is the only time I
think he's ever shouted at me
in my life.
- I don't blame him for that.
- Yeah.
I think that's when he started
showing me scary movies
'cause like-
- I gotta get back somehow!
- He's gotta get me back somehow!
- It's just like that scene in Community
when he walks in with the pizzas
and the whole place is on fire.
- Man, I guess gunpla is
kinda like sophisticated Legos
in some ways, right?
- Kind of, yeah.
- It's like really difficult Legos.
It's like IRL Minecraft.
- Because it's cool, yeah.
- It is.
- The way I think about it
is that you know that
Winnie the Pooh weem?
Weem, you know the minnie
the pooh meme with the one-
- [Joey] Minnie the pooh? (laughs)
- Minnie the pooh?
- Fuck my brain.
Winnie the pooh meme, the
one where he's in a suit
and it's like Legos, gunpla.
Gunpla.
I know gunpla fans will be pissed off
if you're saying that
they're Legos but come on,
they're fucking Legos!
- How dare you compare?
I had these things called,
did you guys ever have
these things called Mechano?
- I had Bionicle.
- Yes?
- Shout out to Bionicle fans.
- Yeah, there's Bionicle.
It was like Lego and then
you move onto Bionicle
which is like kinda difficult Lego.
- Bionicle for big boys.
- And then Mechano introduces screws.
- Oh, I think I remember this!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, and metal parts
and then you can build
tanks and shit out of it.
- [Kson] Screw the parts together?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, so instead of Lego
that just fit together,
you get small screws
and little hooks and stuff
and you actually screw it in.
And then on top of that is
gunpla, that's in my head.
That's the difficulty spike, I feel.
So now that I've spent my
childhood playing Mechano,
I'm like I'm ready for
the next step, gunpla.
- Do you ever get
stressed out building it?
When you're trying to fit a piece together
that feels like it
shouldn't be going together
but the guide is like no, no,
you put that piece together
and you feel like you're
gonna break something?
I was just so nervous around that.
- When I'm building gunpla,
it's like zen to me.
- I feel like you'd need to be.
- Yeah.
- I get too stressed out.
- No, no, no.
- [Garnt] It's very therapeutic.
- It's a therapy.
- It's like doing a jigsaw puzzle, I feel.
You gotta be in zen mode,
otherwise you're just gonna rage.
- We did a race of a gunpla.
- That wasn't fun.
(everyone laughing)
- What happened?
- Speed running gunpla's not fun.
- We did a speed run of gunpla.
- Oh, god no!
- It wasn't gunpla,
we were building Asuna
from Sword Art Online.
So it was like figure making.
- It was a model, yeah.
- It was still a model kit
but yeah, that wasn't fun.
When you add a relaxing activity
and put a time limit on it,
suddenly it doesn't
become relaxing anymore,
what can I say?
- That's why you rarely see
jigsaw puzzle speed runs
just because it would be so fucking-
- [Connor] That sounds
fun, we should have that.
- That's so stress inducing!
I mean, I'd love to do it but-
- This sounds like an amazing idea.
- Yeah, jigsaw puzzle speed run.
- I bet there's strats
we haven't developed yet
because we're just too afraid.
- Everyone's just like oh
yeah, just find the corners.
There must be a way to optimize them all.
Speed runners come on,
get on it, get on this,
what are the strats?
- Are you a big jigsaw puzzle person?
- I love jigsaw puzzles.
- Oh my god!
- Have you ever met anyone
who said I fucking hate jigsaw puzzles?
- Not hate, I've never
met anyone who loves them,
they're just clearly not very polarizing.
It's a fucking piece of cardboard
that you stick together.
What's not to like?
- [Joey] I guess if you
break it down (indistinct).
- It's like saying does
anyone have any angry feelings
towards connect four?
It's like no, it's connect four.
No one feels strongly
about it or against it.
- Feel like people who are
shit at connect four hate it.
- How are you shit at connect four?
It's not hard.
Thank you actually.
- [Joey] Well, tell that to the people
who keep losing at connect four.
- What about naughts and crosses?
What do you call it in Australia?
What do you call it?
- Tic tac toe?
- Tic tac toe.
- I call it naughts and crosses in the UK.
- Naughts and what?
- Naughts and crosses.
It's like Garnt saying barometer.
Naughts and crosses.
- Naughts and crosses.
I'm sure tic tac toe
or naughts and crosses
is stress inducing to
people who are shit at it.
- [Connor] No!
- It's like when you play that one dude
who clearly just knows the winning strat.
- [Connor] Just go for the middle.
- And will just beat you every time.
Then I can start to see
people being like fuck this,
even though it's fundamentally
just a bunch of lines
on a piece of a paper, right?
Can still be stress inducing.
- Right.
- Haven't we talked about this?
- I can't remember.
- I don't know how we got onto this.
- Going back to gunpla, so
what is your favorite model kit
that you've built so far then?
- I've built a Zugoku.
- Zugoku?
- Yeah.
- I know Zugoku.
Why do I know Zugoku?
- Sasuyo Zugoku.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's the one
that's kinda like short and dumpy, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Why did you just say dumpy?
- It's short and dumpy, look at it!
- Yeah, and that was my first RG.
- [Garnt] Ooh, okay.
- It was really hard.
I hurt my fingers.
The parts have to move around the part,
do you know what I mean?
- Oh, without breaking it or anything.
- Yeah, without breaking, it was so hard.
I was about to break my nails.
- That sounds stressful.
- I have a hard enough time
building Ikea furniture.
(everyone laughing)
- It's like that but if
the couch was this big.
- Where's the perfect
grade Ikea furniture?
That's what I wanna know.
- Paging Ikea.
- [Connor] It's already hard enough.
- There's no such thing as
a high grade Ikea furniture.
It starts on like master grade.
(everyone laughing)
- I get PTSD whenever I
thread the screw too much
and then it's like halfway in in the screw
and you're like oh no, oh no,
I've got like three turns
left before this is gone!
- And then it starts making
that horrible squeaking sound?
(Joey groaning)
- I definitely like building
gunpla up to a point
and then you finish it
and then you're like
what's this thing that I haven't used?
And it's the fucking stickers
and that's when it goes
from a relaxing activity
to just the worst thing
I could ever hope for.
- I wish I liked it.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- I wish I was into it.
- [Joey] 'Cause it would
just be something you can do
on a rainy day, right?
But I know there's hardcore-
- [Connor] And my kids
could play with them.
- Yeah.
- You can watch their
soul leave their body,
I think is what happens.
- Ah!
But I know there's hardcore
gunpla modelers in Japan
that go to the effort of
you know when you snip off
the little bits of plastic
and there's those little
bits of plastic sticking out?
They don't just cut it, they sand it.
- I sand it too.
- [Joey] Are you sanding?
- How do you deal with
people back seating you
when you're building it?
Do you have people telling you what to do?
- Oh, there are people every time.
I punch them in the face.
(everyone laughing)
- Just like shut up!
- No one tells me what to do!
I'm a delinquent, I do what I wanna do.
Shut up!
- I will sand it.
I will do what I want but
I'm gonna sand it, okay?
- I will sand it. (laughs)
- As if game back seating
wasn't already the worst thing ever,
could you imagine someone being like um,
you haven't sanded this part enough?
- I didn't realize what
would be the worst thing
to have a back seating
experience with until it happened
and it's chess.
Chess is by far the
worst to play on stream
'cause of back seating.
Everyone is like E4, E4, E3!
Everyone just says shit.
- I can't believe you made that move!
- Sometimes I wish people
didn't know how to play chess.
Maybe they wouldn't backseat so much.
- Playing chess, because I
remember when I played chess
in the chess tournament, I had to learn
to not look at the chat
because you know that sinking feeling
where you've just moved a piece
and you've realized
you've just hung a queen
or something like that?
Playing with chat is just that
feeling but just constantly.
- Are you a chess player?
- No, I know nothing about chess.
- Do you know any strategy
board games like Mahjong?
- I play Mahjong a lot, I love Mahjong!
- You play Mahjong?
- Hell yeah!
- I'm good at it.
I'm really good at it.
- Really?
I got Garnt into it recently.
It got to the point where
I bought a mahjong table
for my house.
- [Kson] Wow!
- [Connor] I'll eventually play it.
- We need to get Connor into it.
- Oh yeah, mahjong stream, let's go!
- Mahjong stream, let's
go, mahjong stream!
- Yeah, mahjong, hell yeah!
- If we played enough,
eventually the viewers
are going to learn the rules of the game.
I saw you streaming mahjong
and how much were the
viewers able to follow along?
- Like 10% of them.
(everyone laughing)
- Some of them were like
I saw my grandma playing this once before.
But yeah, I think it's one of those games
where the more you watch someone play it,
the more you start to understand the game.
I'm not necessarily good at the game,
but I've gotten to the point now
where I watch professionals
playing it on YouTube
and just watching them
play it is like oh shit,
now I understand more now about
the strategies of the game.
- Do they trash talk in
the middle of the match?
- No, they're super quiet.
- I wish it was like poker
where they're just talking shit
to each other the whole time.
- [Garnt] That would be so funny.
- [Joey] We could do that.
- We can start it.
- It's like oh really,
you're gonna cheat right now?
You're gonna cheat right now?
I see how it is, all right, motherfucker.
That's pretty cringe, bro.
- Do you only play online mahjong
or have you ever played with
real tiles as well with people?
- I've never played it with the real ones,
only the online mahjong where I'm learning
from Ryu ga Gotoku, the Yakuza series.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] You learned it from Yakuza?
- [Kson] Yeah!
- I think everyone learns
it from that though.
- They teach you in it how to play it?
- Yeah, so in even Ryu ga Gotoku game,
there's a place where you can go
and play mahjong in the game.
- [Connor] It's like a tutorial?
- It's a mini game.
- Yeah, it's like a mini game, yeah.
- Because that's the thing,
where is the best place to
learn how to play mahjong?
- I learned it through the,
you know on the Nintendo Switch
there's the 50 classic board games game?
- [Connor] That's how you
learned to play mahjong?
- Yeah, and they have mahjong on there
and I was like I'm gonna give it a go
and then I just got into it from there.
- [Connor] Is there tutorials in there?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,.
- If anything, online
games are the way to go
because I didn't realize this
until Joey invited me over
to play physical mahjong,
how much online games
hold your hand to tell you what's going on
and what you can put down
and what the strats are.
So I remember I was a
complete beginner at mahjong,
barely knew the rules,
played once with Joey
and suddenly, it was like
training with a master
and then going back to the novice level
when I played online again.
I was like wait, they highlight
all the tiles for you?
And they tell you all the hands?
What is this baby mode
that I'm playing right now?
- Yeah, because the one time
I played it IRL with Garnt,
we had one of our friends
who's way better at it
and I think I learned 20 new rules
just from that short session.
I was like oh, you can do that?
- You can drop a tile (indistinct).
- I'm not gonna pretend I
understand all the rules
because there are some hands where-
- It's so deep.
- Yeah, Maki would do something
and he'd suddenly get like
10 times the amount of points
that I was getting and I'm just like
I'm just gonna let this happen,
I don't know what's going on
but I'm having fun.
It is a fun experience.
- Yeah, that's rule number one.
Have fun.
- [Kson] Have fun.
- [Connor] I can't show you.
- Do you want to instantly
sound like a boomer?
That's what you have to say.
- Have you ever done any
mahjong streams yourself
or was it just a single player thing?
- Yeah, I did it yesterday.
- [Garnt] Oh really?
Okay.
- Yeah, with my viewers.
I play with my viewers
and it's really fun.
Always having fun.
- Do they not stream snipe you either?
If you're playing with viewers.
Because I did it once on
stream and I got stream sniped.
- I've had that before.
- But there's nothing more frustrating
than getting stream sniped with mahjong.
It's like getting stream
sniped with poker.
- Well, they can look at your stuff.
- [Joey] Yeah, they can look
at my hand just on stream,
it's the worst.
- I just trust them to not
look at my mahjong streams.
- You put a lot of trust in your viewers,
I'm jealous.
(everyone laughing)
- Your viewers are nice.
Would you say that the Japanese audience
is very polite in that sense then?
They won't stream snipe you or
try to fuck around with you?
- Yeah, I think they are.
- Well, that's good.
My chat loves to fuckin' ruin my day.
- [Joey] Same.
- That's what they get off on doing.
I'm kidding, I love you
chat, but fuck you, chat.
My god.
Oh my god.
- Yeah, that's basically
a lot of Western people
are just like, especially
with our audience,
they love to troll us.
That's where the content
is for us, I guess, right?
- Exactly, exactly, viewer interaction.
- So what are your favorite
types of streams that you do?
- My favorite types of streams?
Types, hmm.
Types.
- Like just chatting or games.
- Or gunpla.
- Gunpla.
- Gunpla, I'm into gunpla right now
so I really enjoy gunpla.
- But if you could do
only one type of stream
for the rest of your
career, what would it be?
- [Kson] For the rest of my life?
Then I'll play games.
- [Joey] Games?
- Yeah, games like ARK and survival stuff.
- You like ARK, right?
- Yeah, I love ARK.
- I couldn't get into
that game, I wish I could.
- [Joey] I don't think I've tried it.
- Why not?
You never tried it?
It's a survival crafting
kind of like real ...
- Like dinosaurs?
- Isn't it kind of like a real Minecraft?
- I think so.
- I thought you guys lived it!
(everyone laughing)
- I only know ARK 'cause
my friends who played
the 4xd strategy games,
those types of games.
- [Garnt] What are they?
- Basically strategy on meth.
It's like strategy games
like times a thousand.
They're very hard.
What are they called?
They make Civ look like it's for babies.
There's a bunch that I have downloaded
'cause I tried to play them,
but learning them are way too difficult.
Those types of friends I
have that love those games
love ARK and that's a good
sign for me to not go near ARK
'cause their game taste is horrible.
- It's like Minecraft but
there's dinosaurs in it, right?
- [Kson] Yeah, there's dinosaurs in it.
- You're like a caveman, right?
- You have one minute to sell us on ARK.
- Oh no!
- Go, time starts now.
- Don't you want to punch those trees
and make your own house?
ARK is for you!
- [Joey] Sold!
- What else can we do, Kson?
Tell us!
- [Joey] Yeah, what
else can you do in ARK?
- [Kson] You can poop
with your clothes on.
Sold!
(everyone laughing)
- (indistinct) have an
obsession with this?
- Have you ever wanted to play Minecraft
but poop at the same time?
Play ARK.
- Can you build a bidet?
Otherwise Connor's not
gonna be interested.
- Can you build a bidet?
- What?
I think so, there's a toilet
and you can poop in it.
- Why are you hitting the P so hard there?
- [Joey] Hard P.
- What's going on?
- Poop!
- Never heard poop said
with such a hard P before.
- Jesus, Kson!
- Poop!
- So far the benefits
to ARK are you can poop.
- I mean Trash Taste viewers
should love that, right?
- Trash Taste viewers are sold.
- Yeah!
- So you got ARK, what else are you into?
- I'm into ARK and you know Conan Exiles?
You ever heard of it?
- I've heard of that.
What is that?
- [Kson] Conan Exiles.
It's like ARK.
(everyone laughing)
- Oh my fuckin-
- Only no dinosaurs, there's monsters.
- [Garnt] So it's like Minecraft.
- Okay, okay, what else do you like?
- [Garnt] Is that not correct?
That's what it sounded like.
- It's like Minecraft with HD.
- You're not into Apex Legends,
the one that every gamer in
Japan is playing right now?
- Do you like FPS?
- I do like it but I'm so bad at it.
I'm not good at it.
- Sounds like you like the
crafting kind of games.
- Sandbox games, yeah.
- Crafting and sandbox.
- You like crafting in game and IRL.
- Yeah, exactly!
That makes sense.
- I'm a crafting person.
- How you ever played Subnautica?
- Yeah, I love that game!
- Oh yes, finally!
- That's crafting under the sea, yeah!
- Garnt finally finds a Subnautica fan!
(everyone laughing)
Like oh thank god, I'm not the only one!
- I knew there was another
person, I knew there were!
There are dozens of us!
- You can play that in VR, right?
- Huh?
- VR, right?
- You can play in VR, yeah.
- I've been meaning to play it in VR.
- I've been meaning to
play it, it looks fun.
- It's hella fun!
- Sell me on Subnautica, Garnt.
- Okay.
- [Connor] It's like Minecraft.
(everyone laughing)
- I forgot what I was gonna say.
- [Kson] (indistinct) poop.
- It's kinda like Minecraft
but you can't poop in it
unfortunately, so that's a tick off,
but it's basically like
a survival crafting game
where if you want to
experience thalassophobia
without experiencing thalassophobia.
- I'll be honest, Garnt, I don't
know what that words means.
- Thalassophobia, it's
like a fear of open water.
- [Connor] Did you learn
that from that game?
- No.
- It's a common word.
- How often do you say that?
- As often as I say archipelago.
- Fuck off!
Did you know that word?
- No!
- Exactly!
Get out of here!
What do you mean you don't know this word?
- I actually learned it
because I played Subnautica,
then YouTube algorithm
works in mysterious ways
and suddenly I started
getting recommended videos
about thalassophobia.
- Thalassophobia simulator.
- I'm just like ah, that's
the thing that I feel
when I play Subnautica.
So it's basically just
a fear of open water.
So it's like if you see an image
and it's just you submerged in the ocean
and you can't see an island
or anything like that,
or you just see deep water
that you can't see the bottom,
Subnautica gives you such a good feeling,
or such a great feeling of that.
- I can't imagine that in VR.
That'd be fuckin' terrifying.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] I want to do it.
- I don't think it's actually
meant to be a horror game
but my god, there are some moments
that fucking scare the shit out of me.
- [Connor] I thought it was a horror game.
- It looks like a horror game.
- Everyone's so scared playing it.
Were you scared?
- It's really scary when
you have to go deep down
to find something.
There's a lot of things
hidden in the deep water.
- 'Cause I've seen so
many clips of Subnautica
where you'd just be swimming
and then just a shark comes.
Like three frames, right?
- [Kson] That's like the most
famous part of Subnautica.
- So when you off in Subnautica,
in the shallow area, right?
- The kiddy pool.
- The kiddy pool and you
can see the sunlight,
there's coral around, you're
like yeah, this is cool.
I love scuba diving, this is awesome.
And then you kind of realize soon after,
that some of the things
that you need to craft
aren't in this area that you're in.
So you look over to the area next to it
and it's just darkness
and then you soon realize
that you're gonna have
to build up the courage
to go in that new area.
- So it's Finding Nemo
simulator basically.
- Kind of yeah!
Kind of, kind of.
And what it does such a great job at
is the fear of the unknown
because you don't know
exactly what's in the water
but sometimes you hear
a sound, you look around
and you're like what the fuck's going on?
- Start looking around.
- Yeah, because normally I
fucking hate horror games
because I hate jump scares.
I hate jump scares the
most and Subnautica,
it doesn't intentionally give
you jump scares, obviously.
It's a natural jump scare but
it does give you this feeling
of just uneasiness.
Like you're swimming in the ocean
and you feel someone grabbing your feet.
That kind of feeling.
And it's just a very fun
crafting survival game as well.
Is Minecraft like that?
I would like to know because
then I would play Minecraft.
- I mean kinda, there's some places
you can run into stuff like that, yeah.
- I think whenever you
first meet a creeper
or an enderman, that's pretty
much a jump scare, right?
- You die really easy early
on so it's pretty scary.
- Creeper, not creep.
- If you love Subnautica,
you will love ARK
because ARK, you can go,
what are you laughing at?
(everyone laughing)
What are you laughing at?
You can go down water, you
can go deep, there's caves.
It's ARK!
Subnautica is ARK without
the poop and the dinosaurs.
(everyone laughing)
- Why poop specifically?
- To be fair, name another crafting game
where you can poop in.
Other than ARK.
Is there any?
- [Kson] Is there any?
- I think it might only be ARK.
- ARK is really famous
for pooping, it really is!
- Why?
- Are you sure ARK is famous for pooping?
Or are you trying to make
it famous for pooping?
- Google it right now, ARK poop!
- Why is pooping in the game?
What does that help with?
- You can use it for
manure and stuff like that,
like crafting material.
- [Kson] Yeah.
Dinosaurs poop too and
they poop everywhere.
- You gotta fertilizer somewhere, right?
- I've just seen compilations of Vtubers
reacting to dinosaurs pooping in ARK
and they just lose their mind.
- Does that happen?
- Yeah.
- Shut up!
- [Kson] 'Cause there's a funny sound.
- Of course it is!
- [Connor] Oh my god, the pooping sound.
- Because there's so many
Vtubers that play ARK
and they all lose their
mind whenever they learn
you can poop in the game and
they just laugh their ass off.
I will link you the video.
(everyone laughing)
- [Man] (indistinct) about ARK poop.
ARK poop machine dino
and farming essentials.
- Yeah, you can use the poop as manure
to grow crops in the
game, I'm pretty sure.
- Yeah, and there's a dinosaur
that only exists for pooping.
(everyone laughing)
what was the name?
I don't know.
- [Joey] My entire existence is poop.
- Yeah.
- You know that Twitter account
which is just you can pet the dog?
Which shows different games
and tells you if you can pet the dog.
- Can you poop in the game?
- There's no poop in this game.
This needs to be a Twitter account.
- [Connor] Always gonna be no!
- Called can you poop in this game?
It's an ARK fan account.
(everyone laughing)
- It's like no, you cannot
poop in Legend of Zelda.
It's just all of them except for ARK.
- So are the dinosaurs
actually scary in ARK
or does that even interest
you to begin with?
- You can tame them.
- [Garnt] You can tame dinosaurs?
- Yeah, you can tame them and
you can go to caves with them.
They can fight for you,
they can live with you,
you can pet them.
- [Joey] That sounds cool.
- [Kson] See?
- That sounds pretty damn epic.
- Can you do that in Subnautica?
- No, you can have a little fish tank
where you raise your own fish
but that's pretty much it.
- You can't really train fish, can you?
- You can tame a dolphin.
- In Conan Exiles you can tame human.
(everyone laughing)
- Isn't there a word for that?
- Isn't that slavery?
- Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
- I was like I'm pretty
sure you can do that
in real life as well.
Not that you should, but you know.
- Didn't we abolish
that like a century ago?
- That's how they sell
slavery in the modern day,
it's taming.
No, it's taming.
- Yeah!
In Conan you can-
- I can't believe reality ripped
off Conan Exiles like that.
- With a stick, hit
their heads really hard
like five or six times, knock them out,
and then chain it to some,
I don't know, that something
but make it like labor.
- That's so random that
you play Conan Exiles.
That game was big a few years back.
Does anyone still play Conan Exiles?
- I do.
(everyone laughing)
- Is it still big?
- Why'd you call her out like that, man?
- I don't know anyone else
who plays Conan Exiles still.
- [Joey] That is true.
- Is there only one?
- I remember there was
drama between YouTubers
and one of them destroyed
the other's base or something
and it genuinely caused drama.
They actually had a falling out
'cause you could destroy each
other's base in the game.
- Didn't that also happen in Rust as well?
- I think so, yeah.
- There was drama around that as well.
- Can you do that in ARK as well?
- [Kson] Yeah.
- Yeah, you can do that in ARK.
- Griefing, I think
that's what it's called.
- [Connor] Griefing, that's it.
Toxic.
- Is there an etiquette to the game?
- Normally I think there is
etiquette in games like that.
If someone fucked everything up,
you're like he's not
allowed in servers again.
- Yeah, just ban him from the server.
- [Connor] Yeah, he's banned.
- I imagine this is the perfect concoction
for that fuckin' South
Park Warcraft episode
where there's just one guy
killing everyone, right?
- Classic.
- Pretty much.
- You've been Vtubing
independently since October?
- October, yes.
- How has it been being independent?
- Well, it's really fun, yeah.
I'm havin' fun, of course,
but it's really busy.
I made my first merch in October,
it was my debut merch.
It was really hard.
I hired a manager first time in my life.
I didn't know I was gonna do that.
My daddy is so, so surprised.
I told him that I hired a manger.
What the fuck?
Anime girls need a manager?
What?
- Every anime girl needs a manager.
- Yes, father, this is 2021.
- It's 2021.
- Or I guess 2022.
- Is the merch still on sale?
- It's not on sale right
now but it sold well.
(everyone oohing)
It sold well.
- That's how you can get into gunpla.
Sold so well, I'm getting this real grade,
is that what it is?
Real grade?
- Have to make a real grade Kson gunpla.
Real ARK-y.
- I'd be down for buying a Kson gunpla,
are you serious?
That's the next stage
because plenty of YouTubers
have figures now, no one has gunpla.
Owning a waifu isn't enough,
you need to build it yourself.
- You gotta build her.
- [Kson] Build your own waifu.
- It makes the intimacy stronger.
- It's like I built her.
- Yeah, 'cause when you
started in the Vtubing,
I think you blew up pretty quickly.
Did you expect the reaction that you got
from doing the Vtubing?
- Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Honestly I didn't expect anything.
When it happened I was like ...
- Yeah, 'cause especially
now, the indie Vtubing stuff
is so massive and so insanely competitive.
It's like getting-
- New Vtubers coming up
like 10 Vtubers in a day.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, it's crazy.
- Debut streams, debut streams every day!
- Yeah, I feel every
time I go onto Twitter,
another one of my friends
is becoming a Vtuber.
- I see a lot of Twitter accounts
that have pre debut or something.
That's the one I see now
where they're going to debut
but they haven't debuted
yet, but they're on Twitter
as their-
- Oh okay.
- [Joey] They show a two
second clip, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They're saying like they're preparing.
- Yeah, I see a lot of those.
- It's like three days
'til debut or something.
- Yeah, yeah, a lot of those.
- That's just the magic word, debut.
We have like fucking
what, alpha debuts now?
What else can Vtubers debut?
- New updated model debuts as well.
(indistinct) now.
- 3D debuts.
- You did that, right?
You got a new model made
from the original one.
- Yeah, this is my model 3.0.
- [Garnt] Ooh!
- I saw a model that was quite interesting
where you just had half of your body.
What was going on with that?
Where did that idea come from?
Have you seen this?
- [Joey] No, what is it?
- Do you want to explain this model?
I'll let you explain, I
don't want to explain.
Explain it to the boys.
- Um, you've seen the
one with my real body
and Vtubing head, right?
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] This was so genius from you.
I have to say this was big brain.
This was so smart.
- [Kson] I used my camera
and I didn't want to put my makeup on
so I cut my head off and
then wore the same costume
as my model because I had the costume.
I made the costume myself
and then made the model.
- [Joey] Oh okay.
- Yeah, so I had the same one.
So why not just put my head off?
- [Joey] That's so smart.
- Her head was here and then
you could just see her chest
and I was like Kson, what are you doing?
It was so genius.
- I never seen that.
I thought that was Photoshopped.
I thought that was meme fan
accounts just making that.
- I did a whole stream. (laughs)
I can do it now.
- That was genius, I have to say.
I was very impressed by that.
How has nobody thought of that?
That's so big brain.
- But some fans hated it!
- Wait, why did they hate it?
- I don't know, my Japanese
fans, like I said before,
doesn't like to see the
real world, I don't know!
- [Everyone] Real world!
(everyone laughing)
- For lack of a better
way of phrasing this,
are they scared of real boobs?
- No, it's not like that,
they just want to keep
the fantasy I think.
- [Joey] So yes.
- So yes.
No real boobs allowed.
- It's like that clip from the Simpsons
where Smithers is in the club
and the women are grinding on him.
- [Joey] And he's like ahh!
- Sorry, I'll show you later this clip.
That is so strange though
that they would get angry.
Were they angry or just
they didn't like it?
- Some people got really angry.
- Really?
Wow.
- I guess it breaks the illusion, right?
- But why would they get
angry about it though?
Maybe dislike of it I could understand,
but getting upset over it feels so stupid.
- Yeah, me too.
(everyone laughing)
- I'm glad you agree, I'm glad you agree.
- I'm like what the fuck?
- It's a weird thing to get
angry about to be honest.
- What you should do is you
should just slowly lead them in.
So maybe start off with 10%
3D and then like 20% 3D.
- [Kson] Oh, so maybe they didn't' like it
'cause I went all the way.
Oh yeah.
- So every stream you do,
just take off a pixel.
- Do 50/50, right down the middle.
- Down the middle?
- Down the middle.
- Right.
- [Joey] You can be like Harvey Twoface.
- Yeah, like a movie poster.
You should try that next.
- I'm gonna make someone
mad with that, yeah,
let's do that.
- I guess it's the same
logic of people who love,
say for example, an anime character
but they separate the anime character
from the voice actress.
- Yeah, they want to keep it separate.
- Because they want to
think to themselves oh,
this 2D character is an
actual real character,
not played by anyone but
it's like a real thing.
It's that fan.
- I understand that in an anime setting
because these lines are recorded
and they are then given to said character,
but when you're streaming,
I feel like it's different.
There's always a person.
- Yeah, I still feel that
there's a lot of Japanese viewers
who haven't differentiated
between the two though.
- I just don't understand how you could
'cause the whole appeal of,
if they wanted to be
obsessed with 2D models,
they would just go and watch anime.
- But it's a 2D model
you can interact with
through the chat.
That's where the selling
point is for a lot of people.
- So when you do do IRL streams,
is it your Western audience
that gives you more positive reception?
- Yeah, definitely, definitely yes.
- I think the phrase here
in the Western community
is touch grass.
(everyone laughing)
- [Connor] Referring to what, Garnt?
- I don't know!
- (indistinct) Japanese viewers?
- No, no, that's what we tell each other
when people are too far off the deep end
and they can't tell reality from fiction.
- Yeah.
Before you decided to become Vtuber Kson,
was there a point where
you were like 50/50
or you weren't sure whether to go IRL?
Or was it just you're like nah,
I'm just gonna go Vtuber right away,
there's no doubt in your mind?
- Mmm ...
(indistinct)
(everyone laughing)
Let me say I'm still struggling.
- Oh, I see.
- Going back and forth
with real life and Vtubing,
what should I do?
Because some people really
like my real live streaming
and some people hate it.
And some people really
love my Vtuber streaming
and there's, I don't know.
- [Joey] It's tough, isn't it?
- It's really tough.
I don't know what to say.
There are a bunch of
people watching right now.
- I think you can be honest about it.
- [Garnt] Yeah, you can be honest.
- To be honest?
To be honest, it's really
easy for me to use this model
than to do the real life because
my face is always messed up
and my real room is really messy.
I do not want to film in there.
- I would disagree but all right.
- What?
- I don't think your face
is, quote, messed up.
- You do not know me when I
wake up, it's so messed up!
- You're beat up?
- Point me to someone who is
not messed up in the morning.
- [Connor] That's everyone!
- Everyone looks messed up in the morning.
- Yeah, I would say in
general, just do whichever one
you think you can keep
doing for the longest time.
I used to do only fucking, oh my god,
used to only do Sebastian
from Black Butler.
You know Kuroshitsuji?
- [Joey] Kuroshitsuji?
- Oh yeah, I know!
- My channel, the way I
started my YouTube channel
was I used to just do
his voice in English,
sound really posh English
and all my videos are me
just prank calling places as Sebastian.
- [Joey] I remember back in those days,
the good old days.
- Like cool people like
this, yes, I suppose,
I'm really British.
- Oh dude, the ouji fans
are creaming right now.
They're like ah!
- But that's what he
sounded like in English,
so yeah, I did that for a very long time
but then I was getting to the point
where I was like you know what?
I don't think I want to
be a character anymore,
I just want to be me.
I think I want to be me and
that was what happened for me.
So I don't know.
- You know what?
I don't think I will. (laughs)
- But you know I got a lot of
pushback when I started doing,
well not pushback, just no one turned up.
Nobody wanted to watch.
- That's so normal though.
When you drastically
change your shit that much
it's like yeah, of course.
- What do you mean you're
not a butler in real life,
what is this, what is this?
- Unfortunately not but I wish.
- Who makes the coffee?
- The intern.
- The real butler.
But yeah, I'd say if there's a
part of you that's like yeah,
I would like to do more IRL
stuff I'd say just go for it.
- [Joey] Yeah, just go for it.
- There's always pushback in the start,
but you will gain the audience
of people who appreciate-
- You can't please everyone
is what I want you to know.
- [Kson] That's so true.
- Never ever ever let the
viewers, what they want,
decide what you want to do.
It's your life, not theirs, right?
- True, that's so true.
- I love you viewers though, by the way.
- [Joey] Surprise!
(everyone laughing)
- Let us know down below
what you want to see from us.
- Yeah, sorry if we don't talk about anime
but clearly, we've made
that choice not to.
- Exactly, exactly.
- If you're doing content
that is to appease someone,
you're not making the
best content you can make.
You're making content that
you think is the best content.
- And you're only gonna be
able to do it for so long
until you get to that point
where you just want to
throw everything away
and be like fuck it, I don't
want to do this anymore.
- There are some times in the Venn diagram
where they overlap in
what the viewers want
and what you want, absolute win.
- Right, happy, everyone's happy.
- Happy little accident.
- Unfortunately it doesn't happen often.
- Yeah, the only problem is
that Venn diagram's like this.
It's tiny!
- So before Vtubing you said
you were into cosplaying,
so how did you get into that?
- Oh, it's a long story.
- [Garnt] Ooh, okay.
- I used to love, do you
know visual kei bands?
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Of course, yes, yes.
- Yeah, and I was a
fan of visual kei bands
and that's where I started cosplaying.
My first cosplay was a
visual kei band cosplay!
- What was the band?
What bands were you into?
- I don't think you guys know
it but it's called Gazette.
- Oh yeah, Gazette, yeah.
- Oh you guys know it!
- I don't know.
- The Gazette.
- You don't know?
- I'm not gonna pretend I do, I'm sorry.
(everyone laughing)
- I used to cosplay as a member of that
and other visual kei bands.
That's where I started.
- Like Nightmare and
Gilgamesh and all those guys?
- You know Gilgamesh?
- [Joey] I love Gilgamesh.
- Oh!
Yeah, yeah.
- Cross Faith as well.
- I love Gilgamesh as well,
my favorite character-
- Gilgameshu!
My favorite Fate character! (laughs)
- I love Gilgamesh.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- Gilgameshu!
- [Kson] Gilgameshu!
- Yeah, that makes a
lot of sense actually-
- My cosplay started from there.
It wasn't from anime.
Everyone thinks it's
from anime but it wasn't.
I was banned from anime by daddy.
- I was banned from anime until I became-
- Was visual kei allowed though?
- I don't think so but
my parents didn't know
anything about it so they
weren't able to ban it from me.
- Because a lot of visual
kei bands are pretty raunchy.
- [Connor] I know that.
- If you listen to like Dir
En Grey it's like oh my god,
I don't want my kids listening to that.
Jesus Christ!
- So did you start off
making your own cosplays?
Or did you buy your cosplays at first
and then you learned it along the way?
- No, I was making it
because my mommy is really good at sewing.
She teach me how to sew when I was little
and I was kinda into sewing.
I was really interested in the costumes.
The visual kei bands costumes
are really complicated.
You guys know it?
It's really cool, it's insane!
So I saw it as art and I
really wanted to make one,
so I started it and then I
ended up being an anime girl!
- Did you do the visual
kei makeup as well?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I used to have no eyebrows. (laughs)
- Wait, why?
- [Joey] So you draw it on.
- Oh!
- They don't have it.
- Oh.
- Most visual kei people
don't have eyebrows.
- I did a video with a visual kei band
and I don't remember if they had eyebrows.
I'm trying to remember
if they had eyebrows.
- It's not a requirement.
- You made it sound like it was thing
where it was agreed upon.
- It's like oh, you want
to be in a visual kei band?
Get rid of the eyebrows.
- Funny image of visual kei bands
with the eyebrows photoshopped out.
Have you seen someone without eyebrows?
It looks really weird.
- It looks super weird.
- [Kson] Scary.
- I wouldn't know 'cause I
had to shave my eyebrows off
because when I became a monk
and that looked like ten times weirder
than me having a bald head, right?
But bald head meant nothing
because all I could see
was just my eyebrow less fuckin' face.
It's super fuckin'
weird, I can't describe-
- Wait, did you have the
shaved head with no eyebrows?
- Yeah.
- That's a double whammy.
- It's just like fuckin' Mr.
Potato Head or something.
Even he has fuckin' eyebrows, doesn't he?
(everyone laughing)
- [Connor] He does have eyebrows.
- Big bushy eyebrows.
- When he loses his parts
and it's just like his eyes
and a mouth, that's what I looked like.
It looked so weird.
So I've noticed in some of your streams,
you've done a lot of meme reviews.
- Yeah!
- Yeah, so what?
- That's good, what nothing, I'm smiling!
Connor's smiling, what is that?
(everyone laughing)
- Yeah, so I wanted to
ask what's your opinion
between Japanese memes
versus Western memes?
Because I only get a
glimpse of Japanese memes
every now and again,
so I don't really know
what kind of memes are even hot or popular
or what the sense of humor is.
What is your opinion on that?
- Well, I only review Western memes
so I don't know much about Japanese memes,
but I've seen some and I
only review Western memes
because I understand the jokes.
- Are you trying to say you
don't understand Japanese memes?
- Are you trying to say
Western memes are better?
- To be honest ...
- It's not like it's better.
- Something like drip Goku.
- To be honest, I prefer the Western memes
over the Japanese memes.
- Yeah.
Japanese meme, it's ...
- [Joey] They're so weird!
- So weird and complicated for me.
Sometimes I really don't
understand why they're doing this.
- I feel the baseline Japanese
meme is the same level
as a multi layered Western meme.
It's reference over
reference over reference
to fully understand it.
- Do they have anything like
uh oh stinky in Japanese memes?
- [Joey] I don't think so.
- You know uh oh stinky?
- I don't know that.
What's uh oh stinky?
- It's a really dumb meme.
- Next time you do a meme review,
you gotta put that one up.
- You gotta put uh oh stinky up.
- I want to see her
reaction, I want it on film.
- Let me see.
- We're getting a live meme
review with Kson right now.
- Okay, this is one of
those clips, bear in mind,
this is one where you hear it first time,
this is I don't like this, and
then you hear it five times,
you're like why is this so funny?
- Right, so me and Joey are
gonna talk while Connor ...
- [Phone] Uh oh, stinky! (laughs)
Poopies!
Funny poopies!
- What am I watching?
(everyone laughing)
- The pinnacle of Western memes, Kson,
that's what you're watching.
- [Connor] This is like trying
to explain my job to my mom.
- [Phone] Haha, poo poo poo poo poo!
Poo poo poopy!
- This is like you playing ARK, right?
- Oh yeah, that's like playing ARK!
- She just walks up to a
dinosaur and goes uh oh, stinky!
- [Kson] Uh oh, stinky!
Poopie poop!
- That has 27 million views by the way.
It's why I thought you'd know.
- No!
- I can vouch no, Japanese
memes are not like that.
- I don't know why we have
that kind of humor in the West.
Well, that's some of them
but there are a bunch
of other ones as well.
I do like our memes, very fond of them.
- Yeah, sometimes I
like anti memes as well.
Sometimes, I don't know,
I can't even get my own
humor a lot of the time.
Sometimes memes just don't make sense.
What?
- I don't know.
It is true because it's like
the more memes I've seen
from both the Japanese
side and the English side,
the more I don't know
what's funny anymore.
- I don't know what's humor anymore.
I can watch a standup comedy
thing and be like yeah,
that's comedy and then I
go to memes and I'm like,
is this comedy?
I'm laughing.
- Is this funny or is it entertaining?
- [Connor] I don't know.
- Can you guys describe a Japanese meme
that you found funny?
If you found any funny.
- That's the trick question, isn't it?
- You know the one that
everyone always sung praises of?
Japanese Vine.
Everyone said that was really good.
- I thought Japanese Vine was good.
- Japanese Vine was really good, yeah.
And a lot of Japanese TikToks as well,
minus the ones where it's
just hot girls dancing.
The ones where it's like
actually the Vine energy
coming back onto TikTok, some
of those are pretty funny
but it's I feel like a
lot of Japanese memes
are very surreal where it's
more like what the fuck is this?
More so than this is funny kind of thing,
would you say that?
- [Kson] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We look at it and it's
like oh, this is really weird
but also kind of entertaining.
But you don't necessarily laugh at it.
- [Man] Do you know the
Japanese guy standing
and he's like yamena dekiru?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I know that one.
- [Man] That's so funny.
- That's not a funny meme.
- [Connor] It's just great, I love that.
- But that's a meme,
that's a Japanese meme.
- That's an inspiring meme.
I'm like good for you, good for you.
I can get behind that.
- Yeah, but that's the
thing, I feel in Japan,
memes are used more as a creative outlet
as in like people take a meme
that is not necessarily funny
but they recreate it in
different artistic ways
to kind of be like look what I can do
with this one thing that
everyone knows kind of thing.
Whereas in the West, you get uh oh stinky!
(everyone laughing)
- [Connor] Sus.
- And sus, where it's like it's funny,
is it creative though?
I'm not too sure.
- There are a few words that
meme has just ruined for me.
Among is one of them.
I can't hear among anymore.
- [Connor] Amogus!
I love memes because they
almost paint the picture
of the current time accurately.
You can really get a sense
of the feel for the time
with a meme I think.
- Memes are almost like a language.
- [Connor] Yeah, that's how they are.
- [Kson] It is.
- [Connor] Put them on
a CV, creator of memes.
- You know what?
In fuckin' 100 years, maybe
memes will become a language
in itself because sometimes you see a meme
and you don't understand it at all,
but sometimes you see a meme
and there are so many layers
that are being conveyed in this one meme
that you just get it instantly.
- But then the problem
is with explaining memes,
like to people who don't get it,
is you look like a
fucking idiot when you do.
They're like why are you telling me
that you find all of these
things individually funny
and then when it's combined
you also find it even funnier?
What's wrong with you?
- Okay, okay, but have you ever had a meme
where you've never heard of it before.
Someone shows it to you
and you're just like
what the fuck is this?
They explain why it's funny
and you're like that's not funny.
- I just saw it.
- Every time.
Every meme at the time and then I like it.
- Rewind five minutes ago and it happened.
- Eventually you see it a second time
and you're like ah,
that's kind of amusing.
You see it a third time
and you give yourself a little chuckle.
Come like the 100th time you see that meme
and you're like pissing yourself
at one note in that meme
or something like that.
That's memes to me nowadays,
especially (indistinct).
- It gets to the point where
you just have to listen
to one millisecond of it and
you start laughing, right?
- I've asked a lot of people this,
what's your favorite meme?
- My favorite meme?
- Off the top of your head,
what came to your head first?
- Right now that came to my
head, the invention meme.
Do you guys know the invention meme?
- Invention meme?
I don't know this one.
- Something was invented
in 19 blah blah blah,
but before that boom, do you know that?
- What is this?
- I'm looking it up.
- I'm looking it up as well.
- [Kson] You don't know
the invention meme?
You gotta Google it.
- Has lesson in meme culture made a video?
- [Man] Invention meme?
Is it just text and then-
- [Kson] Text and images.
- [Man] Oh, hold on.
- What about that meme
do you like so much?
- Oh, oh!
Like this one, right?
- Oh, I get it, I see.
I get it, yeah.
- Like depression was invented in 1856,
people before depression.
- Yeah, that one, that one!
- It's like a smiling dude.
Oh these ones, yeah, I've seen these.
- It's better than uh oh
stinky, that's for sure.
- [Joey] True, true.
- I feel like uh oh stinky
has the staying power.
Sometimes you see it enough times
and you're like this ain't funny anymore
and you wake up the next
morning and you're like okay,
this is pretty damn funny.
But that's the best memes.
The worst memes are the ones
where you see on Twitter one
day or you see on Tiktok,
they last literally a day.
I've seen memes last a day
and can you even call
them memes at that point?
- No, it's just a funny image.
That's all it is.
It's just some dude posted a funny image
and a lot of people liked it.
I guess that's what a meme is, isn't it?
- Yeah, I guess that is.
- I guess that's what a meme is.
- [Connor] Congratulations, Joey, you-
- I figured out what a meme is.
- [Kson] That's a meme.
- I mean a may may.
- That's a may may.
- [Kson] May may.
- For the longest time I
thought it was may may.
When troll comics were first a thing.
- It's melee, right?
- [Joey] What?
- Melee, like when you hit someone.
- Like Super Smash Brothers Melee?
- [Connor] Yeah, melee.
- Yeah, it's melee.
- When I was a kid, I could not.
- [Joey] Melee?
- Melee, melee?
- [Joey] I called it
melee when I was a kid.
- [Kson] M-E-L-E-E.
- Because when you see melee
you're like melee, melee?
- That's another one of those words
where I remember me as a child,
I just did not know which one it was
and I would be like Super
Smash Bros (whispers).
- Wait, so is it melee or melee?
- I say melee.
- [Joey] It's melee.
- Melee.
- What do I say?
I forgot what I said now.
- [Garnt] Melee.
- Melee, melee.
- Melee.
- Okay, I'm getting a fuckin'
what's that moment called
where your memory is
different than what people-
- [Connor] Oh the uh ...
- Mandela effect.
I'm getting Mandela
effect right now I think
because I swear when
you booted up the game,
the announcer pronounced it melee.
- [Connor] No, he didn't!
- He definitely didn't.
He goes like Super Smash Brothers Melee!
- It wasn't an American accent,
I swear to god it wasn't.
- But the guy doing it is an American.
- [Connor] Yeah, he's American.
It's Xander, right?
- It's Xander who does it.
- He's the one who does the main voice of-
- [Joey] He does (indistinct).
- He did that?
- It's the same guy.
- He did voice acting for that long?
Holy shit, okay.
- He's the announcer for Smash.
- I did not know that.
- And I'm pretty sure
he says melee, right?
- [Connor] I think so.
- Does he, does he?
- I think.
- Kson's mind is just blown.
- I know nothing about Mario.
(everyone laughing)
I don't know anything about Pokemon.
I know about nothing about Mario.
- That says a lot about society.
- [Joey] That says a lot about society.
- When you play a game-
- [Joey] (indistinct).
- I'll let them finish.
I'll let them finish.
When you play a game, English
or Japanese are you picking,
which one are you going for?
- The first one that popped out.
- [Garnt] The first one that popped out?
- Yeah, if it popped English-
- Oh, you literally like either or?
It literally doesn't matter?
- Doesn't matter for me.
- Oh, wow.
- I guess 'cause you can play both, right?
- [Kson] Yeah!
- [Connor] Oh my god.
- I guess it's kinda the
same with me as well.
If it's originally a Japanese game,
I'll play it in Japanese
unless I have to stream it,
but if it's made from a Western
studio, then I'll play it.
- It's like Swiss people
with European versions.
They're like oh which language?
I speak all of them, doesn't matter.
(everyone laughing)
Fuck off!
Fuck off.
Yeah, so now that we've discussed a lot
about your Vtuber activities,
I'm wondering though,
what's the grand plan for Kson?
What do you want to do?
What do you want to achieve?
- Where is Kson going in 2022?
- Kson 2022.
- Anything you're allowed to tell us.
- [Garnt] Yeah, it's 2022.
- Don't remind me, Garnt.
- I don't know.
I just started off just
being a normal delinquent.
I want to be a worldwide delinquent.
- Worldwide delinquent.
- The world's most famous delinquent.
- Pitbull step aside, there's
another Mr. Worldwide.
- Mr. Worldwide delinquent.
I don't know, I just didn't
set a goal for myself.
- Yeah, just taking it day by day?
- [Kson] Yeah.
- Are you the kind of person
who makes goals for themselves
in daily life or anything?
Or are you just kinda like
a I'll do whatever I want
kind of person?
- I'll do whatever I want kind of person.
- [Joey] Yeah, that makes sense.
- I feel like that's very
common amongst creative fields.
- Really?
- Well, I mean there are people
who are compulsively
planning every little detail
of their creation, but I think-
- I tried to do that once.
- [Garnt] What, plan?
- What happened?
You said it like something
went horribly wrong.
What happened?
- I did that once!
- Yeah, it just broke me down.
My brain couldn't do it.
- So when you are making cosplays,
you're just kind of winging it?
You're like I'm eyeballing it,
you wouldn't measure anything?
You're just like yeah.
- I never measure.
- Oh my god.
- I just brr and if it went wrong-
- I feel that's true talent though, right?
It's like people who are like
I've never cooked this thing
in my life, takes a two
second look at the recipe
and it's like yeah, I
can cook it perfectly.
- People who don't know
how to read the piano,
they just learn it by ear or something?
- [Joey] Oh yeah, people
can hear from music.
- That's crazy, that's crazy to me.
I can't even play DDR in general.
- I can't play DDR either.
- [Connor] How are
people good at that game?
- With practice.
- [Connor] It's insane.
- I don't know if someone
can explain it to me
but can you explain why some
of the most famous composers
to ever live were deaf?
Yeah, how does that work?
- They just knew.
I guess that's the biggest mystery.
Like Mozart was deaf but
he wrote his first symphony
when he was five years old.
No, both Mozart and Beethoven were deaf.
I'm pretty sure Mozart was deaf.
- I'm pretty sure Beethoven was deaf.
- Yeah, Beethoven I think
wrote his first symphony
when he was like five
years old and he just knew.
- Shit man, what was I doing at five?
(everyone laughing)
- I mean back then-
- Destroying Gundam figures.
- Shitting my pants.
- Back then there was only like
now that's what I call music one
'cause there was like
two songs around then.
I'm sure it was easier to get
away with writing a symphony,
you know what I mean?
Come on, there was no music.
- We all know Beethoven invented music.
- Name a song before Beethoven.
- Cave music?
- Exactly.
- [Man] Joey, Mozart was
neither blind nor deaf.
- Oh, really?
- Mozart was blind?
- No, no, he wasn't.
- That's Helen Keller.
- [Connor] I'm glad we fact checked that.
- Helen Keller (indistinct)
- Helen Keller was born blind and deaf.
- I know there was piano battles
they used to have back in the
day, that sounded so cool.
- [Joey] Yeah, it was like a
rap battle but on the piano.
- Where Mozart wiped the floor
with another famous composer
or something I think.
- [Joey] Something like that, yeah.
- He was just such a badass, bro.
You should've seen his hair,
have you seen his hair?
Insane.
- I mean everyone had that
kind of hair back then though.
- It was insane, bro, the
man had a massive mane.
- [Joey] He had a do.
- That man was makin' music.
- Man discovers Mozart in 2022.
- [Connor] He was makin' music.
- You know that new guy, Mozart?
He makes some bangers, dude!
- Oh my god.
- Do you go to conventions?
Anime conventions?
- I've never went to
the conventions before.
- [Garnt] Would you be interested?
- [Joey] Yeah, would you ever want to go?
- Yeah, of course!
- Okay, here's the thing, would you go-
- [Kson] I never leave my house.
- Would you go as your Vtuber model
or would you do the full
RTX render and attend in-
- Like a cosplay.
Would you attend in cosplay?
- I would love to attend in cosplay
with this shoujo cosplay.
- That'd be pretty cool.
- [Joey] That'd be dope.
- Imagine getting a picture
with Kson IRL RTX turned on,
HD 4K 24 hz.
I'm sure people would freak out.
- [Joey] Yeah, that'd be awesome.
- Do you want to go to
cons in America as well?
- What?
- Do you want to cons in
America as well or just Japan?
- I would love to go to
America and do that, of course.
Never done it before.
- American cons I imagine are
quite different from Japanese.
- It is?
- Yeah, I'd say so, yeah.
- From what I've heard.
I've not been to a Japanese
convention right now,
but what Japanese conventions are there
aside from Comiket?
- Sorry, not Comicon, Comiket.
- I haven't been to Comiket
but I've just heard not good things.
- From what I've seen, it's just a line
that you join to buy things.
- Yeah, it's a doujin convention.
- Get in line, buy it and then
get in another line, buy it,
get in another line.
- Credit where credit's due,
I think America has the best
cons and they do it good.
UK sucks.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah, it sucks.
It's so bad.
- UK don't have cons,
they have drinking parties
with some anime figures involved.
- Drinking in cosplay.
- But it's always in a venue
where you'd have a school dance.
It's never an actual venue.
It's small.
- [Joey] It's not like a concert hall.
- No, it's literally
just a place to go drink
for people who like anime.
- One thing I love about American cons
is that they have events going on.
To me, I remember going
to my first British con
and seeing what their events schedule was
and it was basically nothing.
You go there to drink, right?
- Even now?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Even now, yeah.
- Half of my panels were in a bar area.
- [Joey] They have their
priorities straight.
- Yeah, you would have the panel,
if you were perpendicular
to it which was a bar.
So while you're doing your panel,
people are lining up
to get beer and stuff.
- It was basically doing a pub show.
- Basically because they most often are.
- I don't even know what
the biggest anime convention
in the UK is right now.
- Do we count MCM?
- [Garnt] Is it MCM?
- I don't know.
- What doesn't suck in UK?
(everyone laughing)
- [Joey] Wow!
Round of applause for
that, ladies and gentlemen.
(everyone clapping)
I would shake your hand, Kson,
but I can't unfortunately,
but I'll do a virtual handshake.
- [Kson] Oh, good.
- Hold up, where did you hear this from?
Who told you the UK sucks?
Who told you this?
Who told you this, huh?
- Um, what?
I don't hear anything that doesn't suck!
(everyone laughing)
I just needed some
information to change my mind!
- We destroyed the most 5G
towers per person, I think.
- The UK doesn't suck, change my mind.
- [Kson] Change my mind.
- Do you like pubs?
- Uh yeah.
- As a delinquent you
should, then you'll love it!
That's what we have going for us.
- [Joey] You get nothing but pubs.
- We have lots of pubs.
Gregg's, you wouldn't know what that is
but I think you'd like it.
- Gregg's.
- There's a certain chain called Tescos.
- [Kson] Testicles?
- No, not testicles!
(everyone laughing)
- [Joey] Testicle meal deals.
- I'm in shambles right now.
- What name was it?
- We've got a Harry Potter tour.
- A Harry Potter tour?
- Do you like Harry Potter?
- I don't know about Harry Potter.
- The royal family is there.
- The queen.
- The queen, Buckingham palace.
- I'm really finding it hard
to have ways to sell this.
- [Joey] Do you like fish and chips?
- Fish and chips!
- I don't eat fish and chips in the UK.
- I also don't care about
the royal family in the UK.
(everyone laughing)
- We're good at taking ...
- Doctor Who.
Doctor Who is from the UK.
- Welsh, Garnt, actually,
it's not UK, it's different.
Please differentiate.
- [Joey] Nando's?
- Well, that's South African though.
I will say what we're good at in the UK
is taking other ideas and-
- [Garnt] Or taking other things period.
- Don't ask where the British Museum
got all their stuff from,
that's number one if landing in the UK.
- You heard of devious licks?
That was a TikTok trend that UK started
back in the 17th century or whatever.
- We are used to foreign food.
We have a lot of it, it's really good.
I'd say you can get some pretty
good authentic everything,
I guess because we don't have
our own food that's very good,
so we just have all the
other countries' food
and let them teach us how to make it.
- [Joey] It's kinda like
that in Australia as well
though too.
- Northern Ireland and
Scotland are beautiful.
- Wales is beautiful.
- [Joey] Yeah, they're there.
- Have you seen the Welsh flag?
- Welsh flag?
No.
- Castles, we have castles!
- UK has a lot of castles.
- Oh!
- I found something, yes!
- I thought you said curstles.
- Curstles.
- Castles, okay.
Castles, yes!
- It rains a lot.
- Oh, that sucks.
- [Joey] Stay inside.
- I hate rain.
(everyone laughing)
Looks like it still sucks!
- No, stone henge is shit.
Actually, do you like theme parks?
- Oh yeah, of course.
- We have some really
good theme parks actually.
Alton Towers.
Thrill rides.
- [Garnt] Here's the thing-
- Actually really good.
- Yeah, so if you like the,
when you go to theme parks,
do you like the thrills
rides or do you like-
- [Kson] The rides, the rides.
- [Connor] Then you'll love it.
- You'll love it.
- Oh!
- I'm gonna say it, we have
some goddamn good theme parks.
- [Garnt] We do, we do.
- The smiler.
It's so good people lost their legs on it.
- Wait, okay.
- It has the most loops in
any single rollercoaster,
I think.
- Yeah, unfortunately the best rides are
every time you go there,
they're probably gonna be closed down
for some reason or another.
- [Connor] That's true.
- As they always are.
I can't remember that
one ride in Alton Towers,
the full park, that was just the big dip-
- [Connor] Oblivion?
- Was it oblivion?
I can't remember.
- [Connor] Yeah, that's oblivion.
- Okay, so one thing I've never understood
is theme parks that I guess
are actual theme parks
because to me, theme parks
are the thrill rides.
I only care about the rides.
I don't give a shit what
kind of theme it is.
I don't give a shit
what the characters are.
Basically what I'm trying to say is
I don't give a shit about Disney.
- [Joey] Yeah, you're really throwing shit
at Disneyland right now.
- I'm going to Six Flags
and going to Disneyland.
- [Joey] That sounds more like it, yeah.
That's why I don't go to amusement parks
because I don't care about thrill rides.
- I don't know what's wrong with me,
but when I go to Disneyland,
I just feel this creepy
corporate energy of them trying to shove
some kind of happy childhood
on me that I didn't have.
- It is kind of like
happy pills, isn't it?
- It is.
It feels like something
out of Black Mirror
when I'm in Disneyland.
I know it's not, I know it's not.
- [Garnt] Do you like going
to those theme parks, Joey?
- [Joey] No, I hate theme parks.
- I'm not saying everyone
who goes to Disneyland
is being fuckin' fed some fakery.
I understand if you grew up
with it and you like that,
that's totally fair, but
for me, when I'm there,
I get this weird energy
that I'm just like (hisses).
- I just don't like theme parks in general
because I don't like thrill rides.
I don't like rollercoaster
or anything like that
and it's the same thing,
to me, the amusement parks
are the thrill rides
and the rollercoaster.
So if you don't like thrill
rides and rollercoaster,
I'm not gonna like amusement parks.
I'm probably going to
go to like the movies.
- I think it's 'cause
I'm over the age of 12,
I think as well.
- What, with Disneyland?
(everyone laughing)
- The amount of people that I know
that you've just called
out with that one line!
- Basically every female
in Japan you called out.
- I know that's a big
thing, a Disney adult,
and there's a lot of Disney
theme park YouTubers,
did you know that?
- [Together] Yes.
- I know some of them.
- And when I watch them,
it's like they're speaking
in a foreign language to me.
I don't understand.
- [Joey] What do you mean?
- 'Cause they discuss the
optimal route for Disneyland
and argue about what their
optimal route of Disneyland is,
and to me I'm like how about
you all just get turnt up?
Do you need to plan everything?
- What is the selling point of Disneyland?
- I don't know.
- I want to know.
- Do you like Disneyland?
- Why are you looking at me right now?
- 'Cause you're the closest
person to a Disney person.
- That is true, my girlfriend
is a Disney fanatic, yes.
- By osmosis, you must
know kind of (indistinct).
- I really am not trying
to insult Disney fans,
I just don't.
- As the only one who has a girlfriend
who is a Disney fanatic,
I can say that I think
the thing is, Aki's not the kind of person
who goes to Disneyland by themselves
'cause there's a lot
of people who do that.
- [Connor] That's crazy to me.
- She's like I go with other
people to show them around
if it's their first time or
just to see what's updated.
Just enjoy the rides obviously,
and enjoy all the activities
that you can do at theme
parks and stuff like that.
- What activities are there?
What do you do?
- I don't know, I don't go with her.
- You must have been with
her once before, right?
- I've been with her once.
- What did you do?
- I waited around until she
was finished with the rides.
(Garnt laughing)
And ate a bunch of popcorn.
- I don't have a strong appreciation
for the characters and stuff.
- I think that's what it is
because she's a Kingdom Hearts fan,
so naturally she's going to
like Disney shit as well.
- How do you feel about Universal Studios
or that kind of thing then?
- I like Universal
Studios over Disneyland.
- You're more invested, right?
- I feel like it's chill as well.
It didn't feel as intense.
I don't know why.
- It is more chill than
Disneyland, I feel.
- I understand that theme
parks have those actors
that are there for the kids
but there's something just weird about it.
For me, I'm like whoa.
When an actor person tries
to speak to me in character,
I'm like-
- [Joey] I don't really
have a problem with it.
- No, no, I don't have a problem with it,
I'm just like confused.
I'm like oh, what?
I don't know why, it freaks me out.
- [Joey] Why?
- I don't know.
- [Joey] Because it's not real?
- You don't want them to be in character?
- You don't want them to be happy?
- Kind of.
It's like it feels like
they're being held hostage
when they're talking to you.
- [Joey] That's the most British thing
you've ever fuckin' said.
- I know they like it.
I think it's a British
thing, that I'm like ...
- [Joey] They shouldn't be happy.
- I'm like just talk to
me like a normal person.
I don't care if you're Tarzan.
- It's like real life Vtubing.
- I don't know, I don't know.
I think I'm just too
British in some senses.
That's my excuse for a lot of things.
I don't know why I can't
wrap my head around it.
What's wrong with me?
- I think it's because you
know the meta behind it.
You have to be-
- The meta?
- [Connor] I can't immerse myself.
- You have to immerse yourself, I think.
That's the best way to enjoy Disneyland
or anything like that.
- I can immerse myself in
somewhere like Six Flags
or Alton Towers 'cause all I gotta do
is just get on that ride and shit myself
and have a good time.
- But that's the biggest
difference, right?
Disneyland sets itself
up as it's another world,
it's like another country.
- I have no issues with Disneyland.
I don't want people to think
I'm hating on Disneyland.
I can't get into it.
But I always wonder this,
what if you made a theme park
with all of these new
characters that no one knew,
absolutely brand new characters,
and it was exactly like Disneyland
just with characters you didn't know.
If you went in there, you
would think it's creepy
'cause you don't know
any of these characters.
- [Joey] I guess?
- 'Cause you're like what is this?
This is like Black Mirror
if you went in there.
Picture it, you could
literally just picture it.
It would be like a
Black Mirror-esque thing
if you didn't know any
of the characters, right?
- I just don't even think
I'd be able to immerse myself
if I didn't know the characters.
So I would just be like oh look,
there's a guy in a costume.
- But it's only not weird
unless you have characters
you understand, right?
And you understand why
they're doing these things.
Otherwise it's like why are
these people dancing around
and pretending to be happy and this stuff?
It's strange, you know?
- I think you're reading
way too deep into it.
- [Connor] I don't know!
Maybe there's something wrong with me.
- It sounds like you
don't like happy people.
(everyone laughing)
- The UK has trained me
well, Kson, what can I say?
I do like happy people.
I do like happy people!
Thank god, thank you.
- I don't know if there's some irony with-
- The other Brit.
- The two British people and
they're just like I get you,
Connor, it's weird to me too.
I've never enjoyed
seeing people in costume.
- You would be freaked
out if you went to a place
with no explanation, with
characters that you didn't know,
just doing this stuff and
it's all branded and stuff.
It would be weird!
- [Joey] Yeah, I don't know.
- What do you think, Kson, am I crazy?
- [Joey] Would it be weird?
- With new characters?
- Like if you went to a theme park-
- That's like a debut stream of a Vtuber.
(everyone laughing)
- I'm leaving, I'm leaving.
- Have you ever gone into a debut stream
and be like oh, that's weird?
- No, that's the start!
That's the start of the story!
- Yeah, but you don't
go into a debut stream
commenting being like uh,
am I only one (indistinct)?
- Connor, Connor, I got it, I got it.
A theme park of Vtubers.
- What would the rides be?
- I don't know.
- Ride your favorite Vtuber!
- Uh, that doesn't sound good.
- A rollercoaster model.
- Do you normally go to theme parks, Kson?
Have you been to any of the
theme parks here in Japan?
- I want to go to Fuji Q.
- In Japan?
I went to Fuji Q.
- That's the one I want to go to.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, and
I went to Disney world
with my friends, Disneyland
with my friends too.
- Wait, there's a Disneyland
and a Disney world?
- There's Disneyland and Disney City.
- [Kson] There's no Disney world in Japan.
- It's Disney city, Disneyland.
- [Kson] I went to Disney
city and Disneyland, yeah,
I went there.
- Soon there will be Disney sky as well.
(everyone laughing)
- I love learning about Disneyland.
I watch all of Defunctland's
videos, it's pretty good.
I love learning about Disney,
I just don't like Disney.
- [Joey] You don't want to go to Disney?
- No, I just don't want to
go to Disney, I don't know.
- Any good rides in the USJ?
- Yeah, one if you like thrill rides, one.
The raptor one, the Jurassic Park one.
- I don't go on the thrill rides, dude.
- You don't go on the thrill rides?
- No, I hate thrill rides.
- What?
- I hate rollercoaster.
- Why do you hate rollercoaster?
- Why would I pay money to get scared?
- It's not scared, it's a thrill.
- It's adrenaline.
- I don't like that.
- What?
- I don't like it.
- You don't like adrenaline?
- No!
- You don't feel adrenaline
when you do something exciting?
- To me, that's not
exciting, that's just scary.
- [Kson] About theme parks,
that's the only thing.
- That's the only thing I
like about thrill parks too.
- I like when you don't feel
like you're (indistinct).
- That's why I don't go
to amusement parks though!
We've established this.
I don't go to amusement parks!
- I thought it was just
Disneyland you didn't go to.
- No, all amusement parks I don't like.
That's what I was saying,
when I went to Mario World
at USJ a while back.
That's like the first
time in 10 plus years
that I went to an amusement park
because I just don't find
that enjoyable at all.
I'd rather go to the movies.
- [Man] Everyone loves
thrill rides, Fuji Q-
- Fuji Q I've heard is the best in Japan
for thrill rides, yeah.
- That's one I want to go to.
USJ maybe 'cause you guys
have been really bigging up
Nintendo World.
I think we called it
Mario World for a second.
- Have you been to USJ?
- Yeah, yeah, once.
- Have you been recently
with the Mario thing?
- No, no, I don't know that Mario.
- She doesn't know Mario
so why does she care?
- [Kson] I don't know
anything about Mario.
- She called Super Smash
Brothers Melee Mario game.
- You don't know anything about Mario?
- No.
I wasn't allowed to play
games when I was little.
- You didn't play recently?
- [Kson] Um ...
- Like any Nintendo game at all?
- Well, everyone grew
up with Nintendo, right?
Mario and now I can't go in.
- You can't grow up again.
- I can't grow up again
with it, I'm too old!
- So when did you start playing games
and watching anime then?
- Oh that was when I was in college.
- Oh my god.
- So basically when you
started streaming then?
- [Kson] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, so what were the
first games you played?
- The very first one was Monster Hunter.
- [Together] Oh, okay.
- Checks out.
- You went in deep right from the get go.
- [Kson] Yeah!
- Jesus Christ.
- What's your favorite game of all time?
- Of all time is Yakuza
series, Ryu ga Gotoku, yeah.
- [Joey] Hell yeah.
- Why are we clapping?
- It's a good game!
- Just win an award or something?
- It is a good game.
- You've never played it before?
- I've never played it.
- I played Yakuza seven and zero.
- [Connor] It looks fun.
- Is that like Jojo?
Do you have to start on one?
- [Connor] It's basically Jojo the game.
- I know it's basically Jojo
the game in a lot of ways but-
- I heard from my friends who like Yakuza
that it's best to start with Yakuza zero,
would that be correct?
- Is that true, Kson?
- Is that true?
- Um well, Yakuza zero I
think is really the best
but to start?
I think Yakuza one would be
better, the remastered version.
- You don't condone skipping parts?
- You start with one and then you go two.
(everyone laughing)
Three.
So what would you say
is the best Yakuza game?
Zero?
- I would say, my favorite?
Is best.
- [Joey] Ishi?
- Do you know best?
Yeah, I think that was the best.
- Is that like the Kishibe
Rohan of Yakuza games?
- [Kson] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, it is!
But before you play best,
you have to play all the Yakuza
series to know more about-
- So it's literally the
Kishibe Rohan of Yakuza.
- I feel stupid explaining this.
- No, no, no, it's fine.
- It's fine, it's fine.
- [Man] Imagine the
Yakuza series characters
within Edo period setting.
- Yeah.
- Okay, okay.
- [Man] That's best.
- That sounds fun.
- How would you feel if
we started with that game?
- Um ...
- If I messaged you and
said I'm gonna start
my first Yakuza game and
it's gonna be Yakuza best,
what would you say to me?
- I wouldn't say anything but-
- She won't reply.
- You won't understand it
because all the characters
that's on the best, it's the
character that used to be
on the other series.
- That makes sense.
- It's gonna be hard to
understand the characters
if you start from best.
It really makes it ...
- See, that's how we
felt when you explained
that you saw Kishibe Rohan manga.
- 'Cause a bunch of the side
characters turn up in that one.
Like Josuke turns up.
(everyone laughing)
- I think zero is supposed
to be a prequel to one.
So you can technically start with zero
but it would make more sense
if you played one first.
- [Kson] Yeah.
- [Man] So you know the mechanics.
- Because zero came out after one.
- My brain is already
hurting just hearing this.
- Every Jojo fan is like
yes, I understand completely.
- So before we wrap things up,
is there anything you want to
say to your viewers or fans
or our viewers and fans?
- Of course, I need to
tell them I love UK!
Thank you UK viewers, I
love you guys so much.
- You can't say that
if you just shit on us.
- Did I?
- Yes, you did.
- There is now an entire highlights clip
of Kson shits on the UK.
- I can't believe this!
- Oh no!
- That's okay, you're
basically UK if you do that.
You're basically British.
- You're an honorary Brit now
because you shit on the UK.
- Only the French could fuck the UK
as hard as what happened right now.
I guess Kson just proved us wrong, right?
- Where can people find you, Kson?
- Me?
Anywhere on YouTube.
I stream on YouTube, mostly on YouTube,
but I stream on mildom, it's a platform
you can mostly use on your phone.
It's a Japanese platform.
- [Garnt] Oh, okay.
I've never heard of that platform before.
- Me either.
- Oh really?
It's pretty new.
- We'll have all these links
in the description of course.
What else?
Twitter?
- Oh, and Twitter too.
Ksononair, I'm there, please find me.
- You gotta be way more
aggressive about plugging.
You gotta get into it, Kson.
You gotta be like fuckin'
here's where you go,
smack that link in the description,
I'm live every goddamn week!
Like that.
- I'm not like that.
(everyone laughing)
- How often do you stream?
I don't think we asked that,
but how often do you stream?
When can viewers find you live?
- Mostly I stream every
day like once or twice.
- Oh, wow!
- I'm a full time streamer.
- You know people that work full time,
they take weekends off, right?
- I don't.
- I'm not saying (indistinct).
- You know one week has seven days?
- [Kson] Mm-hmm (affirmative).
- And some people decide
to only work five days?
- Um, Japanese people don't.
(everyone laughing)
- True that, true that.
You know what?
Roll the Patreon.
(everyone laughing)
Just show the Patrons!
Can't even argue with that.
I just had to, I just had to.
- She's just destroying
every culture right now.
- I know, I know.
- What do you think about Australia, Kson?
What do you think about Australia?
- Do you like Australia?
- [Kson] Oh yeah, of course!
- Yes!
(everyone laughing)
Yes!
- What do you like about Australia?
- I think they're fun people!
- Hell yeah we are, dog, let's go!
- Are British people fun?
- I've never met British.
I thought British people doesn't exist.
(everyone laughing)
- Well, I am a happy boy.
- You know what?
You do the fuckin' outro.
I don't want to be on
this podcast anymore.
- Gotcha.
Enjoyed the show?
Make sure to follow us on Patreon.
Patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on twitter,
send us your memes on the Subreddit,
hit up our playlists on
Spotify and of course,
go check out Kson at all the links
down in the description below.
But thanks for coming, Kson.
- Thank you for having me today!
- Hell yeah!
- Kson, on this podcast, we're
meant to clown on Americans,
not the Brits.
(everyone laughing)
- I can't believe I don't exist.
Fuck!
- All the Americans are like, first time?
But now you know.
- Is this how the Americans feel?
Fuck, man, fuck.
- I'm leaving!
- All right, have a good one, guys.
See you next time!
- Bye, guys!
- Bye!
(slow music)